Ladies and gentlemen,
the one the only Joey Coco Diaz,
Aka mad flavor.
Tuesday afternoon off the one.
Oh,
one has joined the podcasts.
That's right.
Brian Red Band,
the master blaster.
Reichel.
Let's up and ladies and gentlemen,
we are still sponsored by the
fleshlight.
Before we even get started,
we're going to talk about the rubber
vagina that we use on a weekly who I've
been using it weekly,
especially initially I many times a day,
twice a day.
No wonder the fucking thing is falling
apart,
falling apart at tropical Humbert juice
this coming out of the helmets.
Fucking kill him.
That stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
Plus he's got barnacles on his dick.
That's what happened to sometimes not
rubber burn.
Sometimes you whack off and you leave it
on your leg.
You wake up the next month there's a big
red spot.
Like the fucking hospital is like a
fucking stain.
That's when you know you got to eat more
carrots,
a carrot or a bowl of fucking soup.
It was like UFC 1:14.
Everybody's feet with fucking yellow.
Did you notice that?
It was me.
Everybody,
when they pick up their feet,
when they want,
like the God,
that feet will fucking yellow.
They got to start eating more oranges
after the weigh in.
Cocks up.
Nevermind that powdered water drink.
Anyway,
I don't know what it was.
That's.
It was a weed.
You were smoking meat.
Ayp.
You'd never know.
I always look at the fighters in the
eyes.
I never look at their feet.
Yeah,
I'm just saying they're wrestling there
in that God.
Somebody punched them.
Their feet are up and I'm like,
dude,
that guy's got fucking jaundice and you
know what I'm saying?
You got big foot finish.
Don't you know,
I was just thinking about.
You often often talk about feet a lot.
I don't like feet touching me like
digital.
Like if a man's foot touches me,
I have a fucking heart attack.
I really would like to get their feet in
your face and you deal with and you're
sweaty and their feet are sweaty.
Feet literally on your face all the
time.
Always have their feet on my face.
I was watching.
I was watching the toenails.
Listen to that.
I was watching an old fight last night
and they were going for a heel hook and
I was getting grossed up just watching,
watching.
I touched his feet like I could never
imagine like grabbing him saying like
getting the fucking tate with the show,
Nail Polish and have a fucking.
So if you were going to fight in the
octagon,
you'd want to wear socks.
Oh,
like chocolate.
Dell at the legends you ever see
chocolate fucking 10th planet got combat
boots.
He wears little socks.
Like chuck's a fucking dude like that.
I love all that stuff.
I wonder why you wear socks but maybe
doesn't want to get his feet funky.
The,
uh,
the mats at Legend sometimes people walk
on them.
I love more the old place.
The new place is actually separate.
It's killed me with Jujitsu.
Was that they said over at the place.
A lot of people show up that at work
directly.
Like they had been working 12 hours
having watched that ass and they go to
Jujitsu dog.
If I catch a whiff of ass,
somebody else,
I'm going to be pissed off.
Joe and I can't handle.
I couldn't handle the north south
position sometimes though I would
fucking die and arm pit and my face with
onion in it.
I think I called it that position.
Smell your butt.
Oh,
that's a horrible fucking position
broadcast because that's what it is.
Guys.
Basically hold it onto your hips and
he's got his ass in your face and he's
holding you down and it's a fight and
he's.
Why would you want to do this?
Seriously man.
It's like,
like I get nervous when people sit next
to me at Mcdonald's,
you know like man,
there's a net good.
Another chair right there.
Go Away.
You know?
And you guys are like putting butts in a
weird thing.
Jitsu twos is you go into like a life
and death struggle with some guy you
just met five minutes ago.
Yeah.
Like what's up man?
How you doing?
Okay,
let's roll.
Slap hands and next thing you know
you're trying to strangle each other
with a great sport.
That's what's weird when everyone who
does it is cool though.
That's the thing is like,
it seems like it would be like kind of a
fucked up thing to do,
but the people that do it are so
friendly and cool and everyone's been
tapped.
Everyone's been through the ringer.
Everyone knows what it is,
just you just go out there and do it.
So it's,
even though it seems like it'd be like a
douchey thing,
it's actually very easy.
It's very fun.
You know,
it seems like it'd be like,
you know,
you'd be sweating it,
but it's just,
just do it,
you know,
we just do it for so long.
It's just a part of your day.
Yeah.
But what if you didn't know Joey Diaz
and you're like,
all right,
you enjoy going to do today.
And I'm sorry about the air conditioner
is broke and it's $120.
Oh,
sometimes we have the windows open
because it's hot as fuck in there.
I've dropped 80 pounds and it's affected
my stomach,
which means my ball sack at three sizes
bigger than the last time.
The other day I stumble.
Your stomach somehow was sucking your
ball sack.
That was taken,
the pocket was taken the effect and
sucking,
taking the effect of that ball sack.
You know what I'm saying?
Looking at me to hear the explosion
here.
I'm not going to look at the fucking
fire cracker.
I'm going to look at the explosion.
So ever since I lost the other day,
I stumbled by a Merino.
Sometimes you walk past them or were you
like,
wow,
what happened?
And I looked at my ball sack.
I'm like,
dog,
if I ever I could use it as a colostomy
bag.
It's if double.
If I ever have a brock Lesnar,
fuck it.
Don't put a bag of me.
It's fucking gigantic.
My balls and my dick still got the size
and the and the endurance.
The ball sack doesn't even like.
I lost like three pounds on the ball
sack,
which makes the ball sack tighter.
It's fucking huge.
His balls out and pulled it out.
Joey Diaz is famous for showing his
balls,
famous for showing his balls at the
comedy store,
showing them on stage.
Just walk around,
pulling them out on people because
they're ridiculous.
They really do like,
they look like oranges,
like oranges is in an old ladies
pantyhose.
That's what it looks.
Not believe how different they fucked
her fucking giant man.
They're like this giant.
Why is it that comics all show always
love to show their deaths and Bob's.
There's no other profession.
I think that I didn't work at gateway
and it's like all computer salesman love
ball showing,
hey,
I was listening to open to do the other
day and Louis Ck was on and he was
telling a story about,
uh,
about j dot Moore.
It was on an airplane with him once,
when he was really young and j goes,
if I pull out my dick where you spit on
it and he goes,
it goes from data because I fucking
hated it so bad because I actually liked
him as a person.
He goes,
but it was just fucking fake.
Faggot put away.
It's,
it's really funny.
But the fucking questions pretty funny
too.
If I pull out my dick spit on it.
I mean,
it might've been even funnier if we just
went.
Yeah.
Go.
You know,
why is it though of comics are fucked
up,
man.
We want to do the most.
We want to do the inappropriate thing
all the time.
That's what it is.
The way it guy becomes a comic is all
your life.
People have been telling you to shut up.
That's mean.
Don't say that.
You know,
you're,
you're looking at it the wrong way and
you know,
get a job.
That's what everybody tells comics.
So once they become actual comics,
they just can't wait to do what they're
not supposed to do all the time.
They just want to pull their ticket out
all the time.
They want to say stupid shit.
They want to sing on the airplane.
And Joey did that weird man talk about
that because that was.
I thought we were going to jail.
I thought we really going to jail.
That was setting this up for,
you know what's crazy?
Explain what happened.
We were on a plane.
We've done this twice.
We were on a plane and Joey says that
he's with the band 10 foot screws and
would like to get on the PA relate to on
the PA and sing a song for everybody.
This is how high we are when we fly.
Okay.
I mean he gets on the fucking pa one,
two,
one,
ladies and gentlemen.
And he started to break it into
notorious B I g but with no swears and
no one knows what to do and there's
people like staring at the kids and they
and now say like fuse,
ladies and gentleman,
we have a short presentation by the
band.
10 foot screws.
Yeah.
Then they just let us do it.
Everyone on the plane was sitting there
like,
I shouldn't even say us because if joe
he goes to jail.
I do not want to go down with you.
I shouldn't have been saying I'm against
it.
And we was totally against.
I guess that you guys are just sitting
there like what is going on?
I couldn't believe you not only did it
there,
you did it coming back.
You did it on two different flights and
these are jets.
These aren't like propeller plane.
This is going to remember the mother
that was sitting next to us,
the meat and the kid was laughing and
smiling at church camp.
Mom was.
Yeah,
church and the girl was like 12 and
she's just looking at the camera because
I'm filming it.
She's looking at the camera like he,
he,
he.
This is not,
you know.
And you're talking,
you're rapping over a PA.
That poor kid was loving the chaos.
Wasn't seen post nine slash 11 to 11.
What was it?
Two thousand four.
Something like that.
You can find it online.
What was that Joe Show?
If you Google Joe show.
Joey Diaz ready to die yet.
That's what it is.
That it is ready to die on youtube.
Got One's genius.
That's the best one.
Talking monkeys in space or DVD.
That's out right now on Amazon.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
That.
That's in the video you made,
right?
It's called a talking monkeys in
Columbus.
It's one of the DVD extras on the
fucking PA on two planes.
Not just talk,
sang songs and had stewardesses clapping
along and it was fucking weird.
It was weird.
That was weird that they let us.
After 9:11.
He just met with it.
They just went with.
How does it weave even know?
How did she know?
I don't know,
but it was not American Airlines.
What was it?
Oh yeah.
I think they should have people do shit
like that more often.
Some girl got on the airplane the other
day in Canada and Air Canada and sang a
song like some funny song about your
luggage.
It was pretty funny,
you know,
and she was pretending that she was
trying out for Canadian idol and
everybody gives her a big round of
applause.
Come on.
Really?
He's just really,
really gonna sing.
And she got on the PA and this little
funny song prepared.
It was great.
It was fun.
What do you mean?
It was.
Everybody has to be quiet,
you know,
and once you shut your ipad off,
it should be anything goes.
But nobody breaks the in a flight late
me.
One time we flying it next to Joe Rogan
was fucking brock.
The fights,
those four day fucking protein shake
that.
The one where you were watching the
Antonio banderas thing that you kept
waking know if it was a nightmare.
I was writing to while I was writing.
He was farting and I put it in the blog
and his heart was so bad.
I had to put it in the blog entry.
That was the happy pills.
I do not miss that because I mean ms dot
that was really big protein all the time
and he was always like a man handled
like you'd been at and he would like
literally tortured me with fucking worse
than my father was the one that the
bookstore and Houston when I fought it
and it bounced off the library shelves
on the second floor.
Oh,
fuck it up.
What was the name of that bookstore and
Houston dog.
Oh,
you talking about?
He was sitting in a chair like,
we're read a magazine.
Fuck Joe Diaz.
That's still not as good as tate's at
the comedy store in San Diego.
The comedy store in La Jolla.
He farted in the law.
It was like somebody lit it on fire.
People were running from it,
man.
They were running from it.
That was when we were standing by the
door.
Yeah,
no,
it was.
Yeah,
same weekend.
He farted right by the door and like ran
towards the bar.
His faults had this,
this a robot in the middle of the fart.
Like first you get a hold of the Fart,
joke around you for like four or five
seconds.
Then this complete other things will
evolve.
That would just climb into your nose has
and you had to step out of that fucking
zone and then when you came back into
that zone,
you still smelled a fart in a postmortem
type way.
It was bad,
but not really.
It is flush with fucking real bad.
He said he ain't bars.
Okay.
The chemical.
Now,
Omar,
he's farsighted.
Better credit credit rating than me.
Oh my God is far to a fucking thick.
Like you could smell the root of the
fucking asshole.
Like,
Oh God.
They were living space and he would
laugh his ass off.
He would turn bright red with laughter
because part of it was he thought it was
funny and part of it was shame.
It was all mixed together with horror
because everybody was dying,
screaming,
I don't care what you say.
This part of you.
No one's comfortable with smell and
pretend all you want,
man.
You can cut the kind of far to.
This dude would cut.
Oh my God.
You really never experienced anything.
It.
It's like,
unless you've been around a dude like
that,
it's like pointless to talk to people
about it,
but like,
yeah,
farts stink,
but you don't understand.
This is fucking gas warfare.
It was like a salt.
You have a kid.
When I was growing up front of bosses,
pseudo his family owned the restaurant,
bns fucking ferny bosses.
Pseudo.
It was Puerto Rican and Cuban.
His mother may workshops every day you'd
go in there and destroy your fucking
stomach.
Bernie had the same type of farts as
take a complete different animal of
Florida that grabs you.
It's just like you have to go home and
change your shirt.
Oh,
intake would light would light up in the
airplane.
You could hear people in like 20 rows
back on Jesus and you will look back and
take with his headphones on sunglasses.
It was a big smile on his face.
Fucking chewing gum and ripping the most
horrendous force known to man up against
anyone that's ever lived a tough time
with Antonio banderas.
Oh,
when I followed it and go,
oh my God,
put them in blog.
Oh,
I put it in the blog.
I was in the middle of writing and just
add it.
I know where I see joey do this.
Just lean away from me a little bit.
Just a little lean.
And when Joey.
Oh No.
As soon as I realized what he's doing,
just clearing away you cartoon lifting
up and emotions and stuff like that.
I do that all the time.
Actually went up by myself.
Do you mean not?
Unless I want you to know I'm farming,
you know,
if I'm trying to sneak out a fart and I
take the blame for it,
which I do occasionally,
then I'll just sit still.
Have you ever touched?
Oh fuck.
In the shower and made Donald Duck
Donald Duck,
I inhaled that far.
There's something very satisfying about
farting in a pool or a bathtub as well.
The Irvine Improv and I thought you
would get too high on the wall and you
think like,
I was watching you and I'm like,
ain't nobody walking by me and I cut him
off.
I turned around a waitress,
spray a fucking glasses and I'm like
four girls and they know it's you.
Fuck you.
The only thing next to a smell of Shit
and saying it's 20 feet.
That's a terrible feeling.
When someone walks up,
he just didn't plan it out.
He thought you were in the.
In the Solo.
One time I went to Bob Hope Medical
Center and they did an ekg on me and as
they will pick me up,
it's a small office.
As they were picking me up,
a little came out of my ass.
I just went to the doctor and the nurse
just sit there and looked at each other
and I got up real quick.
Then block them.
Let me tell you something.
When you find a little doctor's office
and they kept expanding,
it was one of those tait farm and so
they just kept getting sicker when they
know it's you,
which fucking embarrassed.
You know,
what I think is interesting,
the whole the idea,
especially amongst comics that you're
not supposed to talk about farts that
somehow another far Taylor.
It's like a cheap laugh on stage.
Is it even a cheap?
I mean it.
Is it not a part of how you look at the
world mean farts are in.
They're in the mix.
I get,
I guess it's like airplanes.
Uh,
if it's about farts,
it's been said airplanes.
You know,
patent did a Joe Patton Oswald did a
joke on his latest cd about going on jet
blue.
It's an airplane choke and I fucking
loved it.
It's an airplane joke about all the
Europeans,
like a sky bus.
Now I don't care if it's a subject
that's been beaten.
I want to hear your take on the subject.
I agree.
Yeah.
And Patents Joking airplanes in Lucy Kay
did one recently on Conan,
I think right now.
Who did you do it on it and he did like
a whole.
Was It on Leno?
Might've done online.
You know,
it's funny though is that we are talking
about fart talking about farts and
airplanes,
but yet we just got done talking about
farting on airplanes.
That's fascinating.
What is it?
What I was going to say is what is about
like things like farts where like,
you know,
if you talk about it,
it's like a cheap laugh and a lot of
times it is a cheap laugh like bad
comics,
but when it's telling the truth,
you know,
when it's you,
you've talked about farts on stage
before and had to be fucking crying
laughing.
It's the truth.
If anybody's smelled tate's Farts,
you will look at far.
It's completely different and it
wouldn't be a hacky situation.
Well it's,
it's.
I mean it's still one of those things
where you think a lot of comics are
always worried about what other people,
especially other comics think about
their material,
so they're scared to talk about
anything.
Even if it's something they're really
thinking about.
If it's like a tired premise,
they don't want to talk about it.
Even if it's,
you have your own unique point of view
on it,
they just don't want to touch on it.
But I don't think that's good either.
Man.
I think you give,
if you give yourself any restrictions,
I mean you can be dwelling on the
dumbest fucking thing in the world,
like the most obvious premise,
but if you're actually dwelling on it,
you should even address the fact that
this is obviously a stupid premise.
Why am I fucking obsessed with this?
But you know,
that's like when you start cutting out
subjects and like fucking,
you know,
like how many comics played the back of
the room,
right?
How many comics do comedy instead of,
for their own,
like their own personal viewpoint.
They do it so that other comics will
like them.
You know?
I mean how many guys remember,
remember in the beginning open mic days,
there were dudes would only make comics
laugh and a lot of guys that got stuck
in this weird spot where they all their,
their audience was comics.
It would be good at making comics lap,
but regular audience members,
which is,
you know,
the comics wanted to see something
fucked up.
Oh,
hi.
Joe Just kicked in and he sat back at
whatever.
Joey sits back.
Let me tell you something.
Whatever Joey says,
bag like this and crosses his fingers on
his chest.
He's fucking gone.
He's gone.
He's on another planet right now with
the acupuncture and then got stone and
we smoked that stuff.
You hadn't.
That put me right the fuck over the
wall.
Do you worry?
Do you ever think about like what you're
talking about on stage or do you just,
you just write out what you're thinking
about?
Like do you ever look at it and go,
hmm,
maybe this isn't a subject for me.
Maybe I shouldn't touch this.
It's maybe three subjects that won't
touch on stage just because of personal
references and I'm a failure for not
touching them.
Really.
You feel like a failure for not touching
them because I'm letting my emotions get
involved.
I don't like abortion.
That's a tough.
That's a tough subject.
I don't like kids with AIDS and punching
kids.
I'm not a big fan of that either.
I've talked,
I've said shocking shit like that
before.
That was mean and funny,
but because it's a weakness to be able
to go off and cover every spectrum of
life.
Right.
But maybe you just don't find humor.
I don't find humor.
I want to talk about a rape.
I don't ever.
I told you about fucking people they
asked that he has.
I've never mentioned the word rape.
Rape makes my fucking neck hair stick up
every time.
So that's,
you know.
Well then that's just you though is you.
There's no reason.
I don't think so,
man.
I don't think so.
I'm thinking.
I think,
you know,
you talk about what you want to talk
about.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that shit on get it.
I put it on the truth about going to
prison,
but I just cannot talk.
Cooktop,
holding the guy down with a machine gun.
You.
I totally understand what you're saying.
Yeah.
It's a tricky.
It's a tricky situation,
man.
Who Does it?
You know,
what gets me about abortion?
Here's what gets me about the abortion
subject.
It's like there's two sides,
okay,
and there's one sign where you are,
you know,
you're a pro life and you don't think
that people should be allowed to have
abortions and that there's other options
and that it's killing it's murder.
And then the other side is,
you know,
you support a woman's right to choose
and it's just a sick.
It's just a series of cells in the body.
It doesn't have a sole woman she's
carrying in our body.
It should be totally up to her.
Why doesn't have to be just two,
two points of view.
I see both.
I see.
I should not be able to tell you what to
do.
I should not be able to tell anybody
what to do and I could totally see
wanting to have an abortion.
You know?
I could totally see not wanting to raise
a child at certain points in your life.
I,
I could totally see you having that
option.
But let's be honest,
what you're doing is you're killing
something.
You know,
you got each growing inside you,
but it will eventually become a human
being.
You know?
I mean,
we can,
we can play games and say,
you know,
at three days,
and it's not at five days,
it is or whatever the fuck you want to
say,
but the bottom line is there's a little
human being growing inside your body and
I think you should be able to do
whatever the fuck you want.
I mean,
it's your body.
I really don't think anybody could tell
you.
You know,
but that's,
you're killing something mean you're,
you're choosing not to let it grow.
You're,
you're terminating it.
I mean,
let's be honest about what you're doing.
It's a symbiotic relationship.
Obviously the baby needs you to stay
alive.
It's a part of you until it becomes its
own individual entity.
But the path has been set.
It's on the way,
you know.
Why is that?
Like how come you can't say that?
I mean everybody you got,
it's either one or the other.
Either you support a woman's right to
choose or you know,
you think it's murder,
but no one ever says,
well,
I support the right for you to do it,
but let's talk about what the fuck it
is.
I mean,
it is a creepy thing and if I was a
woman it would creep me out,
but I would have to do something like
that.
You know,
especially when you talk to someone
who's had kits,
once you've had kids,
you understand what,
what babies really are and the whole
thing,
you know,
you get,
you get this experience of having your
own child,
you know,
and you go,
oh wow.
It's crazy.
The abortions really crazy when you
think about it.
I'm glad I don't have the option.
I'm glad
you know that I don't get pregnant.
Could you imagine if it was you that got
pregnant if like,
you know,
like a bar.
How many abortions would you have?
You'd have to,
you'd have like 10 abortions.
I mean,
can you have your fucking plumbing break
a ceiling to this?
I went,
I went out with a girl once that it
sends so many abortions that she can't
get pregnant.
Really?
Say three or four.
She was so crazy.
I,
you know,
I went to this,
she's had,
she's had like five or six.
She,
so she was so crazy.
I went to this abortion or a show or
whatever it was at the Science Museum.
I guess it wasn't a show convention.
No,
it was just a display that showed from
like every week of a baby's life that
meet thing,
that life thing.
Bodies in motion and they're all in
glass jars though and there.
And at first I was like,
they're not real.
These are just little models.
But then you read down that these are
all real.
Start calling the mother.
Yeah.
And you look at the very small one and
it looks like a little demon.
Like I don't know if you've ever seen it
just looks like an alien or something.
Lizard.
Yeah.
And then it just,
it's so weird seeing a girl,
but then you get to the big one and that
is the most depressing thing you'll ever
see in your life.
Just as baby sitting there with a face
that's been frozen in time.
Like and just,
you know,
it freaks me out and if you don't know
the exhibit we're talking about,
it's a bodies exhibit and this guy
invented some new process of preserving
human tissue and he does it somehow or
another in plastic and they have a whole
video on it.
I think it's called body worlds,
but I'm trying to think of the process
plasta something anyway,
so it's really like a bunch of bodies
all cut up in like in weird positions
doing weird things and you know,
it gives you a sense of the anatomy,
but it also gives you a sense like how
is this any different than something a
fucking serial killer would do?
You know?
Actually,
could you imagine that this was all
started by a guy who's just some sick
fuck.
And the way he pawned it off on people
is like just checking out the anatomy
because there's some of them that are so
questionable.
Dude,
one of them,
they had a chick cut in half at the
vagina and the vagina and there's
segments of her.
She's like cut in half at her fucking
pussy.
Like really tiny.
I really need to see that.
Are you sure?
Are you sure about that?
You sure you want to put that fucking
image?
Pretty fucking demented.
It's weird,
man.
They're like playing tennis and Shit and
you know,
it's just their muscle tissue with no
skin on it.
Fake eyeballs.
It's a trip.
Do we go together to see?
I think we did and we saw the imax movie
a body,
the body gangs.
I remember being so stoned while seeing
that I almost had a panic attack and had
to.
We were so hot.
We had lollipops,
didn't we?
I think we had lost.
This was back in the days.
The rookie days of of edibles will.
We didn't quite understand what was
going on.
They go to lollipops will be fine.
We didn't know the people who don't
know.
When you eat pot man,
you get.
You get way different.
It's a way different high.
It's something called 11 hydroxy
metabolites produced by your liver.
We've talked about it before,
but that's why people freak
out when the brownies and shit like you,
you.
You swore off edibles on Mondays because
the Armenians given me free editable day
on Monday,
so I always eat three peanut butter
cookies and get fucked up.
Once you call,
we will never forget this.
You go like this dog.
That's it.
Dog.
I got one.
No more fucking had apples.
Apples.
Joe Rogan.
I'm done.
Bed had Tivo.
So you feel like you could just record
this.
The recording would be awesome,
but would be more awesome as the visual,
you know to get some facetime.
Facetime.
It's always doing facetime.
Sometimes you eat those edibles and I
them like eight in the morning.
Guys like I get up,
have a cup of coffee,
either fucking chocolate cake by 9:30.
I gotta go rewind.
Fear factor was all edibles because that
would last the longest.
And this is also when I didn't
understand,
I just knew that I build up a tolerance.
If I had a lollipop every day I was
getting blitz greed.
I mean like so baked.
I was like freaking out about the colors
of the sky and you know,
thinking how strange this life is and
we're pretending it's permanent,
but it's really temporary.
While it was like forced to do this,
not forced,
but you know,
while my job was to do this fear factor
show hightest Fox,
if they fuck with you,
those edibles,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
No,
they do really do it.
It's way stronger.
People don't.
It's four times more psychoactive than
thc.
When you eat it,
that 11 hydroxy metabolite,
it doesn't feel like pod.
Does it feel like you're high.
It feels like some totally different
kind of a psychedelic trip,
you know,
very introspective,
really makes you fucking consider your
life.
You know,
when you're alone and you ate a Brownie,
you start going deep into your childhood
and Shit,
don't you thinking about like your
relationship with your parents and
fucking all sorts of weird shit that
made you become who you are and you
start like really fucking going deep.
Last time I did edibles was that at UFC
and oh,
it was with you.
And uh,
it got to the point where there was a
good match going on and everyone was
murmuring,
you know,
at once,
like an arena started that murmur
started to get in me and I start feeling
my heart,
Ms.
Clay,
Guido Diego Sanchez.
I could feel the smacks was one flurry
of the first round where they were both
just look for like a minute,
they must have connected on 20 punches a
piece.
I felt all 20 punch.
I remember that I woke up like this,
like just holding onto myself like I
can't even walk these fucking punches.
That Diego's thrown at me and all of
sudden I realized I had Brian Redman
next month.
And people like jake shields is over
here.
I'm like,
what's happening?
But I caught myself fucking blocking
Diego's body kicks the shit like twisted
and everything.
That's what,
you know,
fuck three d glasses.
When I was in that bucket,
when they broke,
that was a,
that was a very intense first minute if
you remember.
That's what think about edibles.
It swept you.
It just swept me.
I'm like turning and fucking fading and
you know,
make it believe he was jabbing.
Here's the question.
Do you think it's real?
Do you think that the connection that
you have when you get super high,
like especially with edibles,
that weird feeling that you have where
you feel like you can tell that people
are lying,
you can tell if people are upset with
you and they're not talking about it.
If you could tell if they have issues,
I think that's real.
Yeah.
I think it's 100 percent,
100 percent.
It's real,
right?
There's a different level of perception
that comes.
It's like you have a new sense that you
usually don't have,
but when you get sober you all of a
sudden start thinking it's ridiculous
when you sober up because you're not
feeling the same sense and.
Exactly,
but it doesn't mean it's never more
ridiculous.
There is no more ridiculous story than
you're telling someone that you have an
enlightened perspective because you got
intoxicated.
People will always make fun of that.
Like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're high on mushrooms and you figured
it out the world.
Sure you did.
You know,
because when you're sober it seems so
preposterous,
but when you're really,
really high you can see some shit and
you figure out some shit.
Every time you get high you get getting
your car.
Even if it's just go to starbucks,
you always figure out one component of
your day,
like one decision is made and it's made
you know,
and you stick to it.
Since that we'd every reason why people
think it makes you paranoid.
It's making you think about shit.
It's making you consider shit that you
don't ordinarily consider.
And let me tell you something.
We'd in the isolation tank,
my God,
Joey Diaz,
that fucking thing has changed my whole
brain.
It's rewired my brain.
Like I,
I have like all the hardware from my old
brain.
It's still like laying around,
but it's not even connected anymore.
That fucking isolation tanks and just
smoking weed.
I'm trying to figure out how to live my
life as if like I just entered into this
world like 10 years ago.
I entered into a body that's already
existed and already had a history and
already had a bunch of things that it's
already done and dealt with,
and so what have I done?
I've done all this.
Jesus Christ.
What was I thinking when I did that?
You know what I mean?
It's like become a totally different
human being.
Managing like a new life.
That's what like the tank does to you.
The tank is the fucking freakiest thing
ever.
I wish more.
You guys would be into it.
You know nobody.
Nobody does it.
I don't know why you guys wouldn't do
it.
It's I,
I always talk about it.
It is the craziest fucking experience
that I ever do.
It's like doing a crime and going home
and locking your door to smoking a joint
for eight hours.
Sitting there thinking the cops are
going to break in.
That's a horrible feeling.
You get to see fucking life.
Whether it is when you sit in that
corner listening by the stairs to see if
they come in.
It's a fucked up experience.
You think,
well,
you clean your brain out of all the shit
that you've done that's making you worry
about people coming to get you all that
shit.
All the shady shit,
you know,
it makes you clean your brain out.
How come you've never done the tank?
How come you never go in?
I don't fit.
You fit.
There's a giant one.
They have the guy in Venice can make any
size one.
It's a huge door,
Joe.
It's not like you have to.
There's two places.
One is soothing solutions in Burbank.
You could go that's near you real close
and it's a very nice lady.
Death Squad trip and tape it over there
and see what happens.
Let's do it.
Shit.
She's a nice lady.
She's very nice.
Yeah,
let's do it.
I'll do it with you guys.
Let's do this.
Tape it and see what happened.
Make a video.
I feel when I'm taking you guys all
Eddie to and already to.
Let's see how I was going to fuck it up.
Don't start screaming.
He's faking it.
No,
no,
he wouldn't.
If we just all said,
let's,
let's all have an experience that we can
advertise that lady's business too and
the guy in Venice to let's advertise him
too because his place is share.
Is it really bad for labs to shit that
guy his.
He's on another level.
See everybody else's making these tanks
like my old tank,
the one I gave away,
which is excellent.
I mean it's better way better than
nothing.
You know,
it's good.
It works good.
But his are like super thick steel and
insulated and his like maintain
temperature much better and it's much
bigger so you have more oxygen inside of
it and he actually adds an oxygen
pumper,
you know,
an oxygen scrubber.
So it scrubs oxygen,
pure oxygen out of the air and pumps it
into you.
He's just got it down.
He's like,
he's nuts.
I had to float that Dotcom.
He's crazy dude.
But a cool.
The cool kind of crazy and it was like a
mad scientist and he's got this new
thing that I tell you about the new
thing,
the video cameras.
This motherfucker,
you know,
what if you don't know about the
isolation tank with the isolation tank
is it's a tank that was invented by a
guy named John Lilly.
John Lilly was this crazy psychedelic
pioneer from the sixties.
He used to take ketamine and and fucking
lay in the tank for days like he was
nuts.
He used to take acid and this is how I
figured out how to make the tank.
He felt he wanted to figure out a way
where he was completely separate from
his senses so his brain doesn't have to
listen to his body at all and he first
he started out with.
He would be in a tank where he would be
upright and the the head you would float
by the head,
so basically be hanging from your chin,
which is probably not that comfortable,
but you get used to it and then you,
you know,
the rest of you feels like you're
weightless.
But then he figured out all you have to
do is just put a ton of salt in the
water and that'll make your point.
Then you can lie on your back and then
like half of your body's exposed,
so that's the new models.
They all,
they all have like minus 800 pounds of
salt and 11 inches of water and you're
lying in it and the water is 93 point
five degrees,
which is the same temperature as your
skin and so as you lie in it,
you don't feel the water anymore and it
you just dissolve.
You have no body sensation at all and
it's just pure mind.
It's just the mind with no connection to
any,
any input,
so the mind doesn't have any
distractions.
You mind gets to look at your whole life
completely objective.
We're not thinking about your back or
your fucking feet smell or you know
you're touching the couch or you're
hearing the sounds and seeing lights.
It's just pure mind.
And in that state,
that's one of the rarest states on
earth.
There's very,
I mean it's pretty simple to achieve,
but if you think about it,
there's no place like that on earth
where you couldn't be separate from your
body.
Like literally you don't feel your body.
It's just your mind,
you know,
and,
and you get destroyed.
We all get distracted.
Like it's like having a conversation in
front of a giant crowd of people.
Like when you're on stage that's
distracting,
you know,
talking to people,
what people are next to you screaming,
that's distracting.
But what we don't realize is life is
distracting and sometimes you got too
much.
Like why do people who have fucked up
lives like to have a bunch of shit going
on.
You know how many dudes you know,
that complicate their lives on purpose
because they got,
they got some shit going on so they'll
just throw.
I'm starting up a business like the fuck
are you talking about?
You're starting up a business man.
You're a fucking comic,
you're gonna,
you're gonna start up a business.
It's,
but what?
Why is he really starting up a business?
He's trying to distract himself with
more shit so he doesn't have to think
about as shit.
You know?
It's like,
it's a classic psychological ploy your
whole life as a distraction.
You don't even realize it.
Everything you do is constant input
coming in.
You've got to navigate your way through
this world.
It takes away resources,
takes away resources that your brain has
got to get in there.
Joey d is,
let's go burbank next week to fucking
break.
Lets me know if you don't do it,
you have never done it
because I,
you know,
I just,
I don't know.
That's the thing.
It's one of those things.
So if you ever been in the tub before,
you think you avoid that kind of like
heavy lifting when it comes to like the
mind?
Uh,
no.
You know,
to me I,
I have my own kind of relaxing things
that I do and it seems like,
I don't know,
I guess it's not a necessities,
so I don't really need to blow money on
something that,
you know,
do
you have to kind of be a certificate?
Was free.
I would do it every day.
Well let's get you on it then.
We're going to do that.
That's going to be our next video.
We're gonna do the isolation tank.
I'm going to convert all you guys
because I think it's ridiculous that
I've been using this thing for seven
years and you guys don't use it.
I'm sure it's better than a tanning bed
and if you guys are way better jerk off
and if you guys go to,
if you google where to float,
just that term,
there will be a website that will pop
out from somebody,
somebody.com
which are very awesome people that made
my first tank and their um,
their website has a listing of places
where you can rent time on a tank all
over the world,
all different countries,
all the different places it's available.
And a lot of people have used it and
emailed me about it and said that they
found a tank,
you know,
like an hour away from their house or
something like that.
It's a fucking great tool.
It's a great tool for the mind.
You know,
if you're the type of person that likes
to meditate and I think everyone should
know everyone.
I mean,
you call it medical,
you say meditate.
You sound like you're full of Shit and
you're doing yoga with beads on.
You know what I mean?
It sounds like the word meditate has
this connotation is this,
you know,
this fake,
fake spirituality connected to it.
You know,
it's a term,
right?
But that,
but thinking about your life,
it's very important.
Especially in boulder,
they use motherfuck,
Lynn sand,
little words.
There was so many sand aware and muddle
falls in boulder.
I tell you what though,
they're nice,
but I would talk to people and you know,
it'd be like,
you know,
they would say,
oh,
I've got this back injury.
You know,
I can't go to Jujitsu.
I go,
oh,
that's cool man.
You know,
you okay.
You're going to be all right.
He goes,
yeah,
I'm going to this healer.
He's doing a lot of body work on me.
A lot of energy work.
I'm like,
ah,
you pay for that or do you suck his
dick?
Fuck.
He talking about.
He was like totally straight face
going to a healer.
You know,
he's working on me doing a lot of body
work.
He's doing,
oh,
he's doing bodywork.
Oh,
he's healing you rocks and saying
there's a lot of people that make a
living doing that.
Man.
They're healers.
They're like push on parts of your head
and and claim that they healing you.
And.
But the thing is,
if you believe them,
it works.
It works.
That's the crazy thing is like the human
body is so fucking powerful,
but we don't know how to use it.
It's like a computer and we don't even
have a manual.
We're just going into the registry and
fucking with things and you know,
we really don't know how it works.
So you can trick somebody with a placebo
and the placebo,
it's a sugar.
It's just bullshit.
Doesn't do anything,
but because they think it's medicine,
their body fixes itself,
but nobody knows how to fix themselves.
It's crazy.
It's like,
could how come you can't?
The placebo method?
How come you can't just apply that on
your own?
Why don't you?
Why can't you just trick yourself?
He can't.
So then you don't have access to that,
that you know,
that pure belief.
You don't have access to the pure
belief.
You have to be literally.
You have to be kind of crazy to have
access to the pure belief that you can
fix yourself with this magic pill.
That's just sugar.
It's a fucking mess.
Why can't we use it?
We got like.
It's like,
it's like a hidden part of the operating
system.
You know,
you have to press like for keys at the
same time to get to it.
You know?
It's fucked up,
man.
No,
it's really cool to do stone.
By the way.
I just thought of this while you were
talking.
I don't want to lose it,
but I get really,
really baked eats and go into your
garage and get a ladder and if there's a
like one of those lights,
like the garage lights go up through it
with a friend and he both look at each
other's face or you turn off the lights
and he posts.
They're at each other's space and then
you wait to your eyes adjust to the
dark.
Then you flip the light real quick and
you see the other person's face like as
a ghost that's burned into your retina.
Then he'd come down from the ladder and
you just walk around and you'll just see
like this floating head in front of you.
How long?
It probably lasts a good minute and
half,
two minutes to work with black people.
No,
no it doesn't.
Well,
you just,
you just see a community wall upstairs
to put a light bulb on fucking crazy
fucking ladder.
What am I doing?
Do I break my ankle as Casper?
The friendly ghost?
I put Angel Wings on when I call high.
That's too much drama to get high and
stuff.
Thing that you've never experienced.
Try it out.
Why you scared?
You know what?
That's free.
Float tape.
You know what is cool as fuck when
you're high.
The La um,
planetarium or the Griffith Observatory.
Isn't that awesome?
Like when you lie back and he watched
that star show.
Amazing fucking incredible man.
Yeah.
When I went to Hawaii and we went to the
big island and uh,
we went up to the Keck observatory.
So in the top of the big island,
it's this gigantic fucking thing they
have up there.
No telescope.
It's like one of the world's biggest
radio telescopes.
The fucking view up there is insane.
You go up there every fucking star you
see the whole Milky Way,
like you literally see the
stripe,
the Milky Way,
and like 100,000
times more stars he normally see because
it's way to fuck up there.
It's like 10,000
feet above sea level.
You're literally above the clouds.
You drive through the clouds to get to
it because we were driving.
I was like,
this sucks man.
It's fucking cloudy.
We're going to get up there.
We're not gonna.
Be able to see shit and all of a sudden
you pop up above the clouds and that's
where the observatory is.
God Damn Beautiful.
The fucking stars are insane.
It's the best thing you could look at.
It's the best view and we deprive
ourselves from it because the lights
even in la,
man,
even in La,
if they shut off all the lights,
if they shut off,
everything above you would be fucking
spectacular.
It's incredible.
It's the most amazing thing.
Like I stood there and Hawaii looking up
going,
is this here all the time?
This is there all the time and we can't
see it.
You know what?
We have all these stupid gay holidays
like Valentine's Day secretaries that
they.
Why don't they have a holiday where
everybody has to turn off their lights
and there's no electricity for the day?
Have it black out some knuckles.
How awesome would that?
That's the greatest idea you've ever
come up with in your fucking life right
now,
but you know what?
If we had everybody doing it,
literally there'd be nothing from the
horizon.
It would be,
God,
how amazing would that be?
The earth would reset.
It'd be like,
oh,
that's what I wanted to go to Vegas,
and you drive and you're going to the
mountains of Vegas.
They have beautiful views in Vegas,
but because of electricity,
all the God damn light,
those lights,
you don't see a goddamn thing.
You look up in the Vegas night,
you don't see a fucking thing.
He went,
imagine 20 years from now,
Vegas had to shut the lights from Sunday
to Thursday.
You would think of that.
You remember when the Luxor had that
light that shot up in the sky and fuck
it up in the highlands.
Crazy was so strong.
Was fucking with pilots.
Just the other day in la,
there's some guys were a shining a laser
at helicopters and they shined it on a
police helicopter and man,
they're getting like crazy charges
against them.
They should.
They chased them down to my responsible.
Well,
first of all,
it shouldn't be so easy to buy a fucking
laser that you can shoot up to the sky,
that new one that,
that could fucking burn you.
But the one that I got in Georgia.
Yeah,
that one got one or two illegal.
Totally illegal.
That's the only reason why I got it.
Good.
I told him it's legal.
It's like a super powerful laser that
you can like literally go to the moon
with pointing at the moon and it'll
register on some fucking.
Some one of those Russian things.
One of those reflectors on the moon.
Like no bullshit.
This is ridiculous.
Yeah.
There you can buy these super powerful
laser.
That means giant takes d cell batteries
and shit.
Wow.
Yeah.
You can just buy it,
some asshole can just sell it to some
asphalt on top of a building and to
start blinding people.
You're blind,
you're blind,
you're going to fuck with it.
I,
um,
I went outside and was putting little
green lights on all the neighbors'
houses,
like seeing,
like how powerful.
It was.
Insane.
You could see it all the way.
I mean literally shot a straight line
all the way across the valley to this
house that was half a mile away and I
could see it.
Remember those little laser key chains
that came out when like lasers first
came out in [inaudible] 99 to the movie
theater.
I fucking shot him on the screen.
You want to kill him.
You remember that?
That store two wheels and those guys to
having those came out in myrtle beach.
Myrtle beach.
What was the name of that Russian dude
that will always sell shit.
Every Friday.
Bones,
monkey ball.
I still have a bunch of his lighters,
man.
Yeah,
he had light is.
And those lights.
Sliders.
I just saw one the other day around
here.
Yeah,
they were awesome.
He used to have these lighters flip the
top and these little titties would light
up.
It was like a bikini is he's such a
child.
Is he still around?
He's been hanging out more at the rock
bars,
you know,
lately,
like the roxy and stuff like that.
How's he been?
See,
he's one of those dudes that even though
I wasn't like looking forward to seeing
them when I was at the comedy store,
now that I think about it,
I'm like,
what a cool guy.
I always was nice to that guy.
Always talked to that guy.
He gave me his phone number.
The comedy store back in the day had
such a unique community in that parking
lot area.
You know,
that parking lot area was like a Lego
club that we would go to.
It was like a hangout,
you know?
That was like literally half the show
was the parking lot show you put on your
best shows first in the parking lot and
then you started putting on your best
shows on stage stage.
He used to fuck around a lot and the
parking you became.
You became a much better comic in the
parking lot because it was like you,
you got loose in that parking lot and
started fucking around with us and you
don't have any restrictions about time
or agents watching you or managers.
You could just be yourself and you would
fucking kill everybody in the parking
lot and then he would take that and just
go on stage or that stage with the
angle.
But before you were telling jokes,
right?
You were like,
when you first started out,
you would like telling jokes on stage,
right?
Like how would,
how would you look like?
What was like a typical routine?
I have no fucking idea.
You remember what you talked about at
all?
That was a long fucking time.
It was like you would go into a subject
but you wouldn't.
You wouldn't really go into it.
You will get the scratch it and then you
would go to the next subject.
That's cheating.
You didn't,
you never figured out how to get that
momentum.
You know,
you get the momentum from going into a
subject and then really exploring that
subject.
So like,
you take the audience on a little trip.
I know that's how I feel like when I'm
in the audience and I'm watching a
really good comment and they start on a
subject,
I want them to really explore that
subject.
I'm like,
there's a lot of shit and that subject,
let's go in there.
The best guy at that to me when I was
coming up was Richard,
Jeni,
Richard,
Jenny.
I got to see him a bunch of times.
I got to see him once before ever even
did stand up.
Uh,
I was just,
you know,
paying as an audience member,
I got to see him at catch a rising star
in Cambridge.
And it was nice because nobody even knew
who he was back then,
you know,
it wasn't,
wasn't even packed.
And I sat right on the front and the
dude would take a subject band and just
ring that motherfucker out,
wring it out.
He would do a subject for like 10
minutes.
And then right when you thought it was
over,
Bam,
he comes up with something else and more
punchlines and more.
And it was like I was in awe.
I was like,
I don't think anybody does it like that.
I think that guy's one of the most under
appreciated standups.
It was Richard,
Jenny,
you know,
a lot of people like,
they didn't give him the credit that he
deserved because a lot of his premises
were like kind of common premises,
you know,
like,
common,
like almost like a talk show host,
a talk show host.
But like,
you know,
if you're doing a spot on Letterman,
like a lot of his premise is just fit
right into the standard,
you know,
letterman spot.
But he was so good.
It was great.
His presence was brilliant on stage
timing.
His timing was amazing.
Something that just,
you know,
it's a shame.
He was in a plane with me just a couple
weeks before he killed himself,
just a maybe maybe a couple months or
something,
something along those lines.
But he was headed to Austin and we were
headed to Austin to do a cap city comedy
club.
And he was headed there for corporate
gig.
And I got a chance to talk to them a
little bit and say hi to him and he just
like,
you wish it had more,
you know,
but I've never really had like long
conversations with the dude,
you know.
But I always felt like Richard,
Jenny is always going to be around,
you know,
I always see him at the Improv or
whatever and say hi.
And he was always friendly.
So it's like,
you know,
you see them there and you're like,
what are you doing?
You're going to a Gig.
Oh cool.
Wait,
what are you doing?
A corporate gig.
Oh cool.
Cool.
Yeah,
we're doing the comedy club.
Oh,
all right man.
Have Fun.
Cool.
And that was like the conversation,
you know,
it's like,
man,
I wish I had talked to them,
you know,
which I picked his brain.
I've seen bobcat yesterday.
The doctor's office.
Oh yeah.
How's he doing on the way in?
Looks completely fucking different.
Real life.
Like how just glasses.
Weird glasses.
And I looked at him at first and he
looked at me and he's like,
on my bobcat and
no,
he doesn't do that no more.
He was a funny comment,
but it was good to see him.
Bob Camp does not get
back.
He deserves either because bobcat was in
those police academy movies,
so people didn't respect them like as a
comic,
but as a comic,
bobcat was fucking hilarious.
Meet Bob.
Do you remember that cd?
That's fucking
brilliant.
Brilliant.
I never knew he was a comic.
That was the internet,
so I only saw him is he's still doing
it.
Still doing it with them like six years
ago and talking about.
He's like,
man,
that's a long time.
Is he still good?
I mean,
how's your house sets now?
I think he just works for Kim.
All right,
so when he does stand up,
he just does it every now and then.
Yeah.
Every now and then.
We didn't even talk about that.
That's a shame.
He was really good.
Would have benefited from the internet
like crazy comedy clips or twitter at
that time.
Totally.
I mean he was that he was a perfect fit
for the internet.
If the Internet had come along 10 years
earlier,
bobcat was a perfect fit.
You imagined people's careers.
If twitter and facebook and all this
shit like imagine Richard Pryor,
total prime.
If you had a facebook page,
a twitter page,
and all of them.
Kenneth mentioned Tennyson's twitter.
Oh Wow.
Be every day.
Some copy off.
He'll fuck it.
No,
that would have his twitter every day.
It will be awesome.
Yeah.
A lot of guys.
I mean back then unfortunately there was
one avenue,
there was you had to get on television,
you had to get on Hbo.
That would be the big one.
Get on one of those comedy specials.
But now there's so many avenues and so
it's so easy now.
You know,
I always think about that,
like I would have been fucked if it
wasn't for the Internet because I would
have been always labeled as like a game
show host guy.
Like nobody would have taken my comedy
seriously.
You know,
you'd have to,
you'd have to see live,
you know,
to,
to know that I was actually comic first.
I just took fear factor for money back
then.
But if you did like something that you
know wasn't cohesive for a good career,
like nobody forgive you,
you were labeled that guy and then they
moved onto the next thing.
You know,
you wouldn't,
you can't now because of the Internet,
you can completely express yourself.
Like people know exactly who you are,
like this,
this podcast,
you know,
I mean you can't move.
This is like the 26th one that we've
done.
You know,
by that,
you know,
people know who the fuck you are.
You are who you are and you're
broadcasting it back then man,
you could fake an image.
You know,
you could like how many fucking gay guys
were straight and they decided you got
married and everything and at the
Hollywood image and the studio pushed an
image for them and they had press.
People would talk to the press for you
and you had a publicist and publicists
are fucking useless now,
as long as you're twittering,
people know what you're really like,
right?
You know,
look at Spencer Pratt and all these
fucking people.
Anybody like that,
you know,
that they become,
they become popular.
And then they just get to talk.
You could have a million publicist,
it doesn't matter.
Everybody's going to know eventually
they're going to compile enough data to
know exactly what you're really like.
They're going to know your lows and your
highs.
They're going to get them.
Make an honest judgment,
you know,
like Google knows everything about us.
What we were talking about this apple
iphone thing,
the iphone,
there's some new thing where apple's
collecting and sharing iphone users,
precise locations.
And this is what it is,
an updated version of the privacy
policy.
The company added a paragraph noting
that once users agree apple and
unspecified partners and licensees may
collect and store user location data.
So I,
I,
I see what you're saying.
You're saying that it's totally
anonymous and I appreciate that.
But you're selling it.
You're selling data,
you're collecting data on me and you're
selling.
Yeah,
please don't.
they're there.
Gets a point where everything,
everyone needs to make money and I get
that
they're making the money that they're
making.
When you're doing stuff like this,
like these ads as spammers,
you're making money off spammer,
mega money off,
people are going to find out where you
are in spam.
Yeah.
I mean probably that's what it is and
that's what they're doing.
They're trying to find out where you're
at,
where you're buying things,
what do you mind,
and when you do eventually your phone is
going to be like,
it isn't Japan to manage your money.
It's they're trying to customize.
Just like everything.
Customize your shopping,
shopping experiences and everything.
Like we're talking about satellite
radio,
like I am a huge fan of Pandora because
it kind of makes you a radio station
based around what you like and.
And it keeps on getting dreams off your
phone.
No problem.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Especially the iphone.
You'd Bluetooth it right to my car and
it's just,
it's great.
It's like a nonstop radio stations,
satellite radio all based right around
what you like and don't like.
Right.
What I was saying about the phone
eventually becoming money in Japan.
You can buy things with your phone.
You literally,
I don't know if you scan it or you send
something,
I don't know exactly how it works,
but it's commonplace and that's going to
happen over here.
Eventually,
totally not going to start sharing data
and they know where your precise
locations
are and you're buying things.
You're going to get spam on your
fullest.
She goes,
I'm going to happen once you have a
photo or wherever the fuck no where you
at,
but my point is that if why would they
be paying for it?
If they're not going to use it,
if they're gonna use it.
You're going to get some bullshit.
You shouldn't.
They shouldn't be able to sell your
fucking info unless it's benefiting me.
Why would your precise location benefit?
Like the company's development?
I guess that's something that you just
have to be like,
well,
hey,
they don't use it.
Just like why would they was like a
douchey thing that they're maximizing
their profit and one of the ways they're
doing it is by selling your private
information,
private information.
You just become a number.
You can become a digit,
but they know exactly what you are.
What kind of private information is at
your bank account or no?
Or is it.
No,
I think precisely what I think of is
where you go every day,
what your,
um,
what your interests are like if you call
800 fucking sex lines.
So now one of those sex cooperation
calls a t and t and says,
we want to buy,
you know,
names from you of people who use lines.
They just,
well,
you know what?
At least a t and t is working.
How many times have you gotten a call
for a funeral parlor?
Ain't nobody dying with me.
If somebody calls and says,
you want a Dick Sucking at least that
now.
And maybe that's what the fuck.
Nobody say,
you go to vegas all the fucking time
from La.
What do you go to Vegas for?
Either they get your dick suck or the
fucking gamble.
A regular consumer.
So maybe that's the data they're
collecting and when they sell it out to
him,
you know,
how many times did you get closed joe
from people trying to sell you
something?
I'm going emails.
Do you get,
you get a lot of those calls where
people want you to change banks and
interest rates and shit like that.
So how do you think they,
you know,
it's stupid.
So somebody tells your phone number.
I don't think they saw your panel or
your mother's maiden name guys.
I just think they sell your interest
what you be with.
It's very annoying when someone calls my
house and they have my name and they
asked,
you know,
asked me to.
Joe,
are you talking about home phone?
Yeah.
You know what?
Home phones are dead,
man.
I,
I've never.
Since I got rid of my home phone like
five years ago,
I've never had a single stray call ever.
Man.
I'm a little bit old school.
I like to have a home phone number,
man,
just in case I don't want to be relying
on my cell phone.
Right.
I'm a little old school.
You ever go buy a car a week after you
buy a car,
you get an application for a credit card
with you.
If that happens,
it just happens.
I don't get back.
That bought the paper.
Of course all your shit know what's the
worst,
it's where they take a car and put it in
a mall and I was like,
sign up the witness' car.
That is just the worst thing you could
possibly ever do.
Two weeks free of the fucking gym or
anything like that.
Then you see anything online that you
can give you information about your
fuck,
but I always knew they were doing see
once nine slash 11 came dog,
this became more available.
That was what law was passed.
We lost a lot of fucking freedoms that
we don't even know we had.
That's why there's people are freaking
out,
but they don't know that I don't know,
but that's to do with nine slash 11,
but you're absolutely executive orders
that Bush
passed and Cheney pants.
A lot of freedoms pro.
So this is part of the freedoms that we
will lose that people complain about.
I you don't know.
This couldn't have happened 20 years
ago.
That's why I used to get called from
Sealy posturepedic trying to sell you a
fucking mattress and you're like,
what are you talking about?
I don't want no matches because your
name just got sold.
Well,
let me ask you this.
What,
what do you think that.
Why do you think they concentrate on
taking rights away?
Do you think they concentrate on taking
rights away because they're worried that
shit is eventually gonna hit the fan and
then they're going to have to really
figure out how to control people so
they're going to have to have more
regulations,
more ways to lock you up.
Why else would they be struggling to try
to get more control over people?
Why would they be struggling to take
away your rights and liberties unless
there's profit or unless they can
control you in some sort of a time of
great stress in disasters,
just protection.
If you know,
if you don't murder murder one and
you're fine,
you know,
I think they're just collecting
not true because the government can
absolutely target people who are enemies
of the government.
People have taken people out of the
Green Party and put them on terrorist
watch lists and no fly list just because
they protest against the war.
That's fact.
That's already happened.
That's already done,
so there's no way they're doing it just
to protect you.
They're doing it to profit.
They don't need to protect you like
that.
If they needed to protect you like that,
it would be much more obvious.
Sis It at a certain point in time.
It was like how much information is
going to be available,
but about.
I mean right now I can Google Brian
Reichle and find out all kinds of shit
about you.
I can google your name.
I can google my name.
When is it going to be?
Just instantly available to everybody.
Not even a google.
You know what the.
What the fuck is the next thing is
available you think so if somebody is a
16 year old computer act that knows what
the fuck he's doing is available to guys
like me.
I'm a moron.
I don't know nothing about the computer,
but there's a kid right now.
I could press three buttons and he'll
call.
You hear what your motherfucking pending
on your phone.
Don't tell me you know nothing about the
computer.
I saw you twitter from your cell phone.
You're a monster.
Me.
You have a twitter from your cell phone
because Brian said that's my witness
right there.
You know it's going to be crazy.
Base Times six months from now,
facetime hackers are going to bust into
your phone and turn on your cameras and
just watch you.
Whatever is going on in your room and
listen to whatever you're going to
listen to that.
Uh,
I totally,
totally,
totally.
Would that be once it hits a network or
will it be while it's on three g while
it's on?
I don't think it matters.
I think the government could be like,
you know what?
This is what we're going to do now.
We're going to bust,
go through a t and t network.
We're going to fucking use facetime with
team.
Imagine the first fucking court case
where somebody gets busted doing
something like that will come up.
Dudes.
Dudes add keystroke things to their
wives.
Computers,
you know,
to find out where their wife's going and
meeting up with her ex boyfriend and
shit like that.
You always hear things like that.
The guy put a keystroke on skies.
Were
they want to find out what you're doing?
Yeah.
If you have a girlfriend that's that you
want to stalk,
you know,
here's something completely easy to do
that I thought of.
And why are you giving us talking?
Now I'm just to talk to you.
I totally don't.
Have you ever stopped?
Never.
Never,
never.
When you were a young kid,
never drove by a girl's house.
Not like did anything out the windows
in the car and cried.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
That's cool.
Anyways,
normal.
It's.
So if,
say like your girlfriend has an iphone
setup that,
where are you now?
Location thing on her mobile.
Goodness.
And then if you just log in and you know
her password,
you could always check on where exactly
your girlfriend or wife is.
That's just wrong.
Don't do that.
And then,
and then you could send her messages
like,
Hey,
I see you with him.
See if orange juice Jones had that
option,
that song would've never come up to you
and him.
I flat out busted you for a word from
our sponsor.
Hit it Joe Rogan.
And uh,
never be the same.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
You.
I've missed you so much today.
It's just so much I followed you.
Please pull that out.
Pull that up and try that.
That is the greatest rapper of all time.
I followed you yet.
You stone cold.
Busted.
Close your mouth.
He says a bunch of Shit.
What are you even saying?
Orange juice.
Jones.
I saw you.
Just press the only have one song that
don't choose Joe.
Joe was like one appearance with him on
soul train.
We were singing something and nobody
remembered.
That's it.
But I saw you and him walking through
the rain is the shit.
Greatest rap song at the end.
You and him walking.
Shut your mouth.
You cold flat.
Busted.
Yeah.
I love you so much.
I followed.
Was it silly rabbit?
Trix.
If that's what gave us silly rabbit.
Trix African.
Okay.
We have it.
Yeah.
I'm waiting for her.
There's a commercial.
Did you decide what is that?
Stop this.
Why are they 30 seconds now?
I tolerate your 15 second commercials.
If you give me a fucking 32nd commercial
before I watch a youtube clip with a dog
that's barking.
Okay.
Some fucking ten second video.
I swear to God I will stop buying your
product.
15 second commercials is good.
Stop being greedy.
Thirty second.
Microsoft windows.
No Jelly.
This is old old school before.
Was it 84?
Oh yeah.
Walking boom,
boom,
boom.
Oh Shit.
You need a video.
A video for ridiculous is what you
people get in the afternoon.
Can you show the video?
Do that dancing style.
I wonder what he's doing today.
Jones Jones in Dorchester.
He's probably doing some some nightclub
and apparently you got it perfect.
Oh yeah.
People podcast.
Motherfuckers.
What?
The July baby.
Wait until he gets mad at her when he
packs up all the shit.
Man.
He has a conversation with her in the
end when he breaks it down,
breaks it down.
Let's a bitch.
No person.
Strong pimp game.
No,
no,
no.
You don't need no.
Come on man.
People can live.
Look at him.
That's the real black man,
right?
White dudes will floss with their
clothes like a black guy.
Does.
Very few white guys dress like that were
fucking burgers and suits and shit like
that.
Someone's gonna come along and do that.
What does it some white guys not wearing
like crazy suits and birds and shit like
that.
Big fucking diamonds,
but saying like totally white oriented
movie.
John Meyer.
Magic John Meyer started dressing in
furs and diamonds and shit.
Big Fat Pinky rings and a fucking cane
with a dragon's head on it.
A silver cane.
I've been.
Why not?
Dude?
That guy is fucked.
Every famous woman on the planet.
He might have.
He might as well just go all out.
Just go straight pimp style.
Have a bucket and diamond encrusted
staff.
Here it is to a Rambo,
Jamey and flat blast.
Web W.
pretty $700 in 1984.
Hold on my credit card.
Yeah,
it all.
No,
I can't give you advice.
She's on the street now that cars
driving by.
Silly rabbit.
Trix kids without be let go.
It's my word.
I forgot all about that.
That was half.
That song was like r Kelly.
Oh beautiful.
Wow.
That's the original art.
Kelly,
who's the original art Kelly,
except Bob Kelly's.
Much more ridiculous.
I didn't have the Internet.
See they will show him pissing off.
Kelly was so much more ridiculous.
R Kelly's the best guy sent me was
fucking amazing.
Yeah.
He's yelling at us saying shit,
what is it about black black culture
where the black guy never loses and
black culture and am like,
not all obviously,
but in shit like this,
like these kinds of songs and like the
art Kelly type songs or like superfly
movies or something like that.
There's something about never lose it.
You can't get me out already planned
this out.
There's something about being clever,
like have you ever listened to the
superfly ever watched super that one of
the greatest blacksploitation movie
everlasting and is so brilliant.
Um,
I took a hit on you.
So if anything happens to me,
you're dead.
Like damn.
He got them.
He got the man he planned in advance
that something faced with garbage
candidate.
Oh,
it's so ridiculous,
man.
Those old blaxploitation movies were
awesome.
But there's something about that to
suppress culture that just wants to win
no matter what.
You know,
I don't think white people will ever
understand that.
You'll never understand.
Never understand what that's like to be
an orange juice Jones.
I mean that's why.
That's why white people can't wear those
links.
Coats,
you know,
who is that kid in Miami?
There's one kid who's like a beat maker.
He's made a bunch of beats for like
really famous hip hop artists and he
made millions of dollars.
But then he wound up blowing it all on
cocaine is a big article about him and I
think it was esquire,
esquire or Gq big article about them
recently.
No idea.
Some famous beat guy.
I'm sure if you go look on Orange Juice
Jones now did he die?
Dorchester Bro.
Can you imagine?
Like if he just works at a grocery store
now and he.
But he still goes,
I'm ordering students Jones and I
recommend this orange juice like a
years.
Google,
Google orange juice.
Where is he today?
Yeah,
I bet he's got a website and a
community.
Hey,
check my twitter.
I told Scott Storage.
Thank you very much.
A Y,
k o seven o was another guy.
Got It.
Get mobile to you.
Take your iphone and that way you with
miss.so
much a fighter jet,
silly rabbit really wasn't following.
It wasn't even stocking.
You were allowed to what you had to
because he couldn't just text somebody
and say,
where are you bitch?
Those days,
man,
guys must've just had extra families all
over the place.
Right?
I found him.
Where was he?
Alex?
After Joan's failed to have significant
follow up success,
he left the music industry to tend to
his terminally ill mother and raise a
family.
He helps us son Douche or into that
orange,
one orange [inaudible] better known as
Mooky with his rap career in addition to
producing it,
score music for commercials and
independent movies.
Jones also contributes to a number of
hip hop blogs,
including Houston's just flipping.com
or global grind.
That's it.
Wow.
Well,
now we know about orange juice Jones
fucking out there in the community
keeping shit popping.
He said,
I've done standup comedy if he wrote
those lyrics,
you know,
because that sounds like pretty,
pretty funny.
He would have to be funny on purpose
now.
That wasn't funny.
Seemed kind of humorous.
No,
I don't think so.
Humorous in like.
Got You.
Yeah.
What?
You're laughing at his and he doesn't
understand what you're laughing at.
You're laughing at it because it's
ridiculous.
If you laugh,
he would even look at you go when you
left without out what I'm talking about
woman,
fine clothes.
Gucci is diamonds,
37 lakes poetry.
It is,
but you have to really mean it in order
for it to be poetry.
If you're just pretending like,
you know,
is that there was that black
exploitation,
a parody that came out recently with
Michael John White.
I didn't hear anything about it,
but I,
I didn't.
I didn't have a desire to see it because
they were trying to pretend they were
making a fake movie.
Like there were doing it on purpose.
Like they were acting funny.
If you're acting ridiculous and you
think it's cool,
it's not funny if you're trying to be
funny,
acting ridiculous.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like,
it's funny.
I mean it's okay,
but it's never as funny as someone who
really,
you know,
saw you sit down baby.
Not unless it's way more funny when he's
like r Kelly.
That's the genius of the r Kelly video
is that that guy really thinks that way.
I guarantee what I always used.
Joseph went to the studio,
started saying that like,
people just like,
I know what I'm doing.
All right,
let me just lay this shit down on this
bitch,
Bro.
They ain't going to work.
Watch my shit that he just said it.
And he goes,
I said,
it's staying.
They argue for a little while.
I wonder when
people break up with orange juice,
Jones said like,
what are you going to do?
Walk in the rain.
You're fucking retarded.
You know,
like,
write a song about me,
asshole.
Move on with good life.
Keep me out of your shitty fucking cds.
Ooh.
Then have you ever had a girl tell you
to not talk about her in your act?
No.
Could you see the other thing is stan
hope road about a Bobby Barnett.
You know he's got that joke about this
chick Bob Barnett to fuck them.
That's like way too hot to fuck him,
but she fucked him and you know,
it's like you can't take that back at
thousand repo men can't take that back
by minute.
You fucked me and he put it in is taking
to take the edge off.
It was like,
it's closing bit.
Well apparently
this chick contacted him.
It's on.
If you go to Doug Stanhope Dot com,
it's on his website with one of his
blogs.
This chick contacted him,
you know,
just like you sick.
Fuck,
I'm a born again Christian now and all
this.
So he wrote this fucking a new basically
a new bit explaining you fucked me.
You can't take that back.
He redid the bit,
like even funnier in a blog,
you know,
talking about times and things that have
happened and what,
you know.
I always wondered what you were you up
to these days.
The where are you now?
Screen.
That plays in my mind.
Very funny man.
Very funny shit.
You never had a check till.
You're not talking about her in your
act.
I had one ticket man,
because she 99 point nine percent
positive cheated on me.
She went away and she went on vacation
and she got fucking rug burn on her
back.
She went to Florida to visit her cousin
or cousins a whore.
Okay.
She went to visit her cousin in Florida.
She had fucking rug burn on her back and
I had my hand on her back and I felt
something and I pulled up her skirt,
turned around.
I looked at,
I go,
what the fuck is on your back?
And she goes,
I was drinking.
Oh,
I was drinking and I was leaning against
this thing and there was like a nail on
it.
I go,
there's a nail.
I got nailed in that.
I go,
you didn't feel the nail.
You just kept rubbing your back back and
forth on the nail.
I go,
that's not carpet brand.
What are you saying?
I'm saying somebody fucked,
you know.
No,
I go,
okay.
You're saying that no one fucked you.
No,
it's not carpet burn.
I told you I was drinking.
I didn't know what I was doing and I was
like leaning against this thing.
I was like this crazy lion bitch.
It was like the dumbest lie ever.
Like this dumb whore.
Didn't even know that she had this
fucking scab on her back getting fucked
so hard.
Probably in the dirt somewhere.
Crazy bitch.
She's probably on destruction site and
an asphalt parking lot of broken glass
and 21 or 22.
I think maybe I might have been a little
older.
Um,
but it was ridiculous,
but I'd already cheated on her so I
didn't care.
She was like,
it was a bad relationship.
I didn't enjoy it.
It wasn't a fun one,
but I,
she keeps,
she keeps a comedy show that night with
me,
you know,
as she got back or can you close on this
and that.
And we went and we left.
I don't even remember if I fucked her.
Probably not because I was probably
grossed out,
but it took her to my comedy show.
She wanted to come with me and she was
planning on it,
so I got on stage and immediately go
into the whole fucking story about my
girlfriend,
go into a spring break and coming back
with rug burn and I had,
you know,
like what,
what's worse,
and then I put that one out.
Like how would you react to that one?
And then I tell the whole story.
She was fucking furious.
She was so mad.
She's like,
if you have fucking believe me,
I go,
I believe you.
But it's funny.
It's just a joke.
I'm just making.
I'm just pretending that you really did
fuck somebody on stage.
The best thing about facebook,
the best thing about facebook is finding
your old babysitter and like,
I remember this babysitter,
it was just fucking hot and she's still
pretty hot,
you know,
now she's still the church.
You have a kitchen.
She never touched me,
but what she let me do it.
Let me put my head in her crotch.
Like,
like sleep in her crotch.
You know
what I mean,
and then like I would move my head
around and she would like kind of like,
you know,
squeezing my head and it was,
I just remember what's so fucking.
How old were you?
I'd probably say 11,
10 little pussy,
Pussy.
He was giving her a fucking forehead and
then,
and then the shorts,
I remember she would just have the
blanket over her and like be watching TV
and I'll be like underneath the blanket,
just do whatever I wanted to.
And then there was this one time I
remember if it's the best feeling in the
world,
I remember I climbed up,
put my hands on both sides of her tits
and just laid on top of her since she
let you do that.
Yeah,
that's great.
So anyways,
I found her on facebook.
Chick is crazy.
She's a fucking child molester.
Ten years old,
making you eat a box.
She's fucking high.
It doesn't matter.
It's like your bit.
I fucking loved it.
It was the greatest thing in the whole
entire room you think it is.
Do you think that she's just a total
attention whore and she just couldn't?
I don't think anyone was.
I think she was probably 16 or 18.
She was just like,
okay,
this is great.
Anyways,
I found her on facebook and she's still
kinda hot and she's divorced.
I said,
hey,
will you get drinks sometime?
Wouldn't that be cool?
Wish you wish you live a Delaware,
the Delaware,
Maryland shoe.
You are you planning on trying to bang
this out?
But I think that would be kind of high
to Banger to bang them.
Know we started something 30 years ago.
That would be the longest relationship
I've ever had.
Maybe like five years old than you.
So she'd be like 40 you think?
Yeah,
something like that.
So 40.
So it's probably still lubing up itself.
Still still do it once.
Get out of,
in and out.
See what's all about.
If you got her pregnant,
she got her pregnant and then we both
have molested a girl child.
See you just did what we were talking
about earlier.
Don't.
I'm just kidding.
That was completely.
Yeah,
I know.
I need a cell phone.
Wait,
what if she fell in love with you?
What is she's always been a love with
when you were 11,
but now I do know.
I know.
I know how gross is the when when
someone says we were meant to be
together and you just want to get the
fuck away from them.
Like be the kids.
See that and you're like,
oh my God,
do you know how much you annoy me?
You know how much I can't wait to get
the fuck away from you telling me we
were meant to be together.
Some people just want someone.
They get so poisoned by music and songs
and stories that they want it to work
out the way it does in the movies.
They want it to be like that.
They wanted to be some special person in
their life.
So even if it's not a special connection
that you have with some person,
they're like,
pretend it is because that's what
they've always wanted.
They want to be in a fucking Sandra
bullock movie.
Right?
It's tough,
man.
I can't stop thinking about my
babysitter's tits.
Oh,
that's a doctor or do any of that?
Creepy Shit when you were a child.
I had a 21 old chick that used to grab
my deck when I was 13.
I didn't actually fuck her,
but she would make out with me.
I would tongue kiss her and she grabbed
my dick.
I was try,
I was going to fuck her,
but I told I couldn't get it up.
I was like totally paranoid panicked and
I was like,
I couldn't.
I didn't know exactly what was going on.
Like I had never even orgasm before.
I never masturbated before.
Nothing.
So I went from nothing to this woman.
She was 21,
she had tits and ass and she was
Indiana,
have a boyfriend who was a construction
worker who was this fucking big manly
dude with hairy chest and he would be
doing his fucking construction work bare
chested,
like in the neighborhood.
And I was like,
this was her boyfriend and this bitch
was right.
Apparently anybody could fuck her.
Oh you have to do is ask and she would
just let the whole neighborhood just
fucked her.
You know?
She was just completely insane and she
had me come over when I was like 13 and
I was like,
there's no way this is really going to
happen.
She's fucking 21.
I'm 13.
How she even living at home with all
these thoughts are going through my head
right.
Next thing now she's grabbing my Dick
and she's sucking my tongue.
Wow.
What the fuck?
I'm like this crazy birch.
Once I fucked me and I'm 13.
Wow,
that's awesome.
There's a lot of those chicks out there,
man.
I used to take,
me and my friend would take all the
neighborhood girls.
There was like four of them and we'd
line them up and make them all take off
their pants and it would stick like
pencils and him and smell ironman and my
friend was just like,
he was.
He was more.
You put pencils in their pussies.
Yeah.
And what do things like that like was
like playing doctor or something like
that.
You fucking great.
How many girls?
You must've cancels in your fuck.
You grow.
Fuck that up.
That fucking sexiest neighborhood.
You know?
It was the sexiest neighborhood in the
whole entire world.
Pencils,
pencils up your snack.
My cousin was.
She wasn't really,
you know,
when your parents are tight with
somebody.
Right,
right,
right.
Same time.
And I found her on facebook too and then
when she didn't reply back to me,
I started thinking about all those times
I used to give her a stabbing when I was
like 11,
that she was like nine.
I would feel a stomach and explore with
this theme.
She was pregnant.
I was fucking with Y'all when you were
11.
I would go down to Miami for the summer
Banger Banger.
You put your Dick in your ass up like a
cat.
You know what I'm saying?
So you didn't actually get it in there.
Who knows
that you started sex at 11.
Then I had another girl that had hair on
them.
Let's see.
She lives in the Bronx and I wouldn't go
up there to spend it with her and her
family on the weekends and I give her a
little fucking millennium.
The girl that I told you that had a
bunch of abortions,
that was also.
I was very young by the time I got
older,
she had all the abortions,
but when I was young I dated her and
this girl,
all you have to do is touch or tense,
just touch them.
And she would start freaking out and go
with this.
I,
I don't know what it was like and I
thought that like that would happen with
other girls too.
And he touched a test and I'm like,
yeah,
okay.
Touching my tests.
Come on,
let's keep going.
You know,
but it wasn't the same effect.
I'm like,
are you the broken?
What's grabbing your ted?
Why don't you freaking out?
Right.
It's like go into like spasms.
Oh,
just touching her fence.
Catholic school.
That's that ship.
I would get new babysitters and I
thought they were all the same.
So like I would get a new one and she'll
walk in and I was smack her in the ass.
She's like,
what?
What is that?
That happened to me,
the girl who molested me when I was 21
when she was 21 and I was 13.
I started playing with real girls after
that,
like my age and when they're my age,
you know,
I'm like crying to try to grab their
aunts or something.
They'd be like,
what the fuck are you doing?
I'm like,
I thought we were going to do it.
Boys and girls do we know they didn't
want nothing to do with it.
They're like,
you can't just jump right into finger in
me.
You've crazy asshole.
That's the problem with any early sexual
experience.
If you're having a sexual experience
with someone who's older than you,
like you're just jumping right into the
pool.
So all the,
all your contemporaries,
you know,
like everyone's going to go through this
like trial and error process.
It's normally 15 year olds and 16 year
olds and whatever.
They just start playing with each other
and then they start fighting,
but they're doing it all together.
You just hop right into someone sucking
your dick some crazy bitch that fucks
everybody on the block and you're like,
what?
So this is what we do.
We just start fucking right and we'll go
from nothing to hanging out with this
whore.
There's funny,
that first girl ever tongue kissed a I
found on facebook recently and I,
she is the biggest white piece of trash
ever and she's got like a hundred kids
and she lives in Florida and we found a
video of her and she's like,
oh,
I don't know who's talking about snoop
dog,
but I don't like it was and she was fat
and it was like this dream girl that I
think about all the time in my head,
like frozen in my head and now I see her
and I'm like,
oh my God,
that is so awful.
It's funny when you look back on the,
the,
you know,
the different types of people that you
kind of experiment with when you first
start dating,
when you're young and you don't even
know what the fuck you like and all of a
sudden you catch yourself out with some
chick who's just completely nuts.
Think about how many fucking nasty
bitches you dated in your life.
Joey Diaz.
One that showed up at rasp was done on
the show.
Oh,
in between shows and she weighed 400
pounds.
It looks like she had the add.
Thanks.
She called rascals the night before.
Joey.
You don't remember me from the sixth
grade?
Yeah.
Marjorie.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
Come on down.
That showed up.
That bitch was for 80.
Tipping the scales.
A nickel and you should've seen me
backpedal.
It isn't.
I'm going to suck your fucking come
down.
I can't wait to fuck you.
All this shit.
And she didn't tell you to fuck 10 years
ago,
but she threw her when she.
Here's the Franklin at the black dog guy
came to get me.
He's like dog,
there's a fun bitch wait for the door.
But to a black dude for 80 blonde with a
fucking cadillac.
He went bananas,
bananas and I went out and I was like,
rascals down.
Let's show off route 34 down the block
from that crazy strip club where they
have no air conditioning.
No.
What's the name of that place?
I forget this,
that all that shit was on the shore was
the rascals down the show is to shut.
Those were totally different animals
than the rascals in west orange.
Yes,
totally different humans.
Yes.
Rascals,
West Orange,
like a lot of cool people,
normal people that worked in the city
and commuted,
lived in Jersey and you know,
it was a nice neighborhood,
rascals down the shore.
We're fucking savages.
They were barbarians.
They're a totally different crowd.
Right?
The sure savages they are.
It's funny.
We knew about that a long time ago,
but now the whole world knows about
that.
Those you ever do those?
Bob Gunzel gigs?
Dental Jersey shore.
He just contacted me on facebook saying,
Oh yeah,
he's buckled a few rooms.
I was thinking about going to Jersey and
uh,
he does,
Asbury park or something,
but like six rooms.
Those rooms.
Yeah,
the summer.
I did a bunch of his gigs.
Fuck yeah,
I did all.
I did the TV show for him.
I did one where he had,
there's a guy named uncle something or
another uncle floyd.
No uncle political,
Lloyd's comedy,
something.
Uncle Floyd was at this guy and like
puppets and shit.
And he apparently had a TV show that was
like really popular in Jersey.
I did that show and uncle floyd would do
standup and I didn't know who the fuck
he wants and this uncle floyd goes up
and fucking levels the place and I can't
believe this.
I can't believe what I'm watching it.
But to them it's like nostalgia,
you know,
like they're loving it,
they're going crazy and I'm like,
wow,
I had no idea this guy was popular.
So I had a fall uncle floyd and I was
eating Dick,
eating Dick onstage falling uncle floyd.
Nobody wanted to hear me,
you know,
like they had just heard this guy and
was like really famous,
you know,
and I had no idea.
Where did you shoot this at?
It wasn't a shot.
This wasn't a TV show,
this was just doing standup in Jersey.
It wasn't cheap,
but it was right on 68th and was right
over the bridge.
I don't even remember that.
It was a place that was on the beach.
It was a place that was actually on the
beach.
It was like an outdoor little venue and
it probably sat like maybe a few hundred
people,
maybe two,
300.
I don't remember,
my memory's real shaky from this time,
but I remember this guy went up and I
had never heard of them,
but they went nuts when he went onstage
almost like,
wow.
And then they told me,
oh,
there's a local New Jersey television
shows,
like really popular,
like Whoa.
But it was like really clean too.
So after that,
that's the worst thing you want is
someone killing when they're clean and
then you go on.
I have to run 30.
Especially if nobody knows you,
you just feel like such a sack of shit.
There's a really great topic that I
started on your forms that just has been
becoming popular again in the last two
days.
And I don't know if you've ever read it.
It's called the story of Haley Riley and
uh,
I just retweeted it on my twitter at red
band,
but it's about this girl that I used to
be really good friends with that I met,
met on the Internet and every time I
was,
uh,
I would talk to her on the phone.
She would send me pictures.
She was fucking gorgeous.
And one time in Arizona we were talking
and she wanted to meet me,
but,
uh,
she,
she acted really weird and wouldn't come
see me and stuff like that.
And she said she has a secret or
something like that,
whatever.
It was kind of fucking weird.
So I stopped kinda talking to her after
that because it was kind of creepy.
Anyways,
uh,
I,
lately I got an email from a guy and he
goes,
you know,
he's asking me if I knew that knew her
and what I thought about her and stuff
like that.
And there's this long email and there's
this whole backstory of this thing on
your forms on,
so check it out.
But it turns
out this girl was just like a huge crazy
fat girl,
you know,
and she just made up a fake personnel if
faith name.
She stole somebody's identity,
like took all their photos from like a
myspace or facebook.
And she's been doing this for about 10
years.
And uh,
this guy flew down,
got a hotel,
fucking spent all this money than met
the girl.
And she was completely different from
what she is.
And,
and now there's photos of what the real
person looks wise guide took this photo
and took like the whole story and made
like an article about it.
No,
he,
me and him just emailed back and forth.
He started sharing photos.
We start talking.
I have the whole thing of like know that
you knew about it because uh,
I think back in the day I,
uh,
somewhere like in live journal or
something like that.
Uh,
I had my old website on their connected
to our somehow and he was just asking if
I ever knew her,
if I still talked to her and he was just
trying to know that he wasn't some fat
guy pretending to be some guy because
she's totally.
She sent me,
like he starts sending me photos and we
figured it out and everything out.
And I tried to confront Haley and,
and you know,
she wouldn't respond.
Anyways,
that was two years ago and now there's a
new victim read on the message board is
called what it's called,
the story of Haley Riley.
And it's on the front page of the messy
l e y h a I l e y last name is r e I l e
y and it's all my people go to forum dot
Joe Rogan Dot net.
It's in the shit talking one on one.
Yeah.
I posted on my twitter to read band.
Wow.
Interesting.
Can you imagine being that person?
That's gotta be a weird fantasy world.
Some new guidance is emailing me like it
just happened again.
Then playing the sims.
How's that different than playing world
of warcraft?
What's the playing world of warcraft?
Yeah.
What's the point?
She's talking.
You're not a fucking wizard.
Okay.
She's not a hot chick,
but she's pretending and she's having a
good God damn time.
She's running around just scamming dudes
and getting them to fly in and visit
her.
And she's.
She's probably crazy.
So weird though because your forum
members,
four members have been saying,
oh,
I got the same thing happened to me.
Oh.
And there's like three different side
stories now.
The completely of the same topic.
That's kind of cool.
Yeah,
I think it's kind of interesting.
You know?
Crazy.
I mean,
she's not hurting anybody,
it's not asking for money except for the
guy that's flying out and spending money
on fucking promise.
If you play that fucking game,
you should get busted.
Did I ever tell you this is a crazy
story that tries to fly her out?
Supposed to fly her out?
He played fucking stupid.
I totally made a bad move.
Rook takes bond.
I totally forgot about a story that I've
never told you and I.
It's the only time I've ever fucked a
fat chick.
The same thing happened at one time,
like a really fucked one.
Fat,
like a real one,
you know?
Not like a,
like a little chunky.
I'm familiar.
It was making me fucking nervous when
they're around me to hug him.
It was an aol first came out,
they used have profiles,
kind
of like facebook Spec in the days and he
would chat to people and stuff like
that.
This girl had a fake all these fake
photos of.
Actually it wasn't fake.
It was when she lost a lot of weight or
something like that,
and then she gained the back maybe 100
pounds or something and she wanted to
get laid.
She lived near me.
We used to private chat all the time.
Uh,
so I was like,
one day I got really horny and I was
like,
fuck,
you know what,
let's meet and I'll pick you up,
come back to my place drinking and
fucking.
She's like,
Oh yeah,
let's do it.
So anyways,
I come to her sorority,
her sorority house,
I come there and I'm like,
uh,
I see this big group of girls and I see
this,
this hot girl.
And I'm like,
oh,
there she is.
And then that whole,
that whole girl got blocked like an
eclipse of this fat girl that came into
my vision,
like,
and like stepped in front of the girl
and it was her and she was like a blonde
chick,
probably about one 80 maybe or 200
maybe.
I mean she was big and tall,
like five,
four,
five.
It was big,
but her face was cute type thing and I
was so like,
I remember driving back to my place.
I'm like,
this is bullshit.
What do I do?
Do I just stopped the car?
Why do even let her in the car?
So anyways,
I got drunk and I fucked her and then I
took her right home and I,
I
deleted her.
I've never talked again.
And.
But you know what if some of the best,
some of the best pussy over there,
fucking juicy chicken weight watches.
Now that's she's about one 90.
Yeah,
bitches banging and I feel like talk to
her.
I feel like going up to him going,
what the fuck you want to lose weight
for a look at that.
As you know,
we'll look at that fucking monster.
But monster that she said that counting
points,
it's a waste of fucking time.
This chick's pretty hot.
Some dudes love a thick girl.
Some,
some dudes just love it.
They do not like fit girl.
Fucking Russian.
We'd store on sunset across from rock
and roll routes and you look at that
behemoth of a chicken.
You come out and talk to,
you wouldn't fuck this chick to death.
She's hotter than hot and this bitch,
everybody who goes in there walks out of
there mummified because you can't
believe you want to fuck a little
milkshake and how fat.
Fifty pounds overweight.
Yup.
Big Fat washing.
Her name is Natasha.
She's dirty about.
And this chick just throws heat from the
fucking.
What is it about Russian brides?
There's like a hardness that's like
extra dirty,
but you don't want to go to sleep with a
fucking scar where your kidneys was
something need to be taught a lesson.
You know,
I've waited online.
I've seen how the guys looking at guys
with chicks guys and a handsome guys.
Check her out.
Like,
you know,
man,
I would fuck.
Just tell she's dirty.
But you could tell she's hot.
She's young.
Twenty two,
page 22 and big catcher now.
Yeah.
Actually now before it all goes.
So she looks like one of those girls
that just big boned.
But she'll take you for the ride.
The fucking light that asks is good when
you eat that ass from behind this Steve
Pounds overweight and you're eating her
ass.
50.
Say Bro.
Sometimes I'd asked is good.
They're eating cake cake val and dairy
queen.
That acid is good.
Yummier for me.
I've never been a,
you know what?
I never fucked a chick fat when I was
drunk or nothing like that.
But I think I had like a girlfriend
once.
I was little on the heavy side of
stabbing.
When you're doing unschooling?
No,
no headphones.
The um,
the,
the famous girl ever fuck was probably
about one slash 70,
but them,
you bring in some ways.
I was probably about one 70 at the time.
So I looked at a special place for about
what?
I weigh [inaudible] she's shorter than
me,
but thick.
It's so unfortunate.
You know,
it's a very sad thing when you see a
girl who like could be so hot and she
just got some weird food thing going on,
you know,
DNA to be thick and this girl would go
back and forth.
Fake chicken,
a fat check.
There's a big difference.
But this girl would like to see if she
would have these weird eating things.
Go on this weird eating beyonce.
She's thick.
You can tell a white burger.
You asked what the fuck the world up to
get her a little bit.
Yeah.
She goes,
but right now she's perfect.
She's.
She's just.
She's got that one foot up in the air
and she's balancing.
But as long as she's balancing God.
Damn.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the perfect shape.
Like beyonce body.
She's not.
So dudes like,
who know who likes.
I don't get that whole skinny obsession.
The girls in Hollywood with this fucking
the stick figure body.
What is that?
Is that girls doing it for girls?
What does,
what does,
what does that really passionate sheep?
Is that what it is?
It's totally the fashion industry is the
magazine industry.
It's all that.
Did they look better in those kinds of
clothes?
But they don't realize.
They don't.
They don't look better to us.
Frank's can't haunted this motherfucker.
Air Conditioning unit was crashed.
This skinny,
skinny,
skinny girl and get stabbed.
Was that pussy good at?
Were you at university?
A little pussy.
So they always get that big bone in
front of the the doodle doodle.
They're so skinny.
Sometimes you're reading the noon one,
get bang like a fucking.
It takes somebody hits you in the
fucking fucking bone is right there.
I want a woman with some fucking heat
down dog.
Tell me the truth.
Seriously,
you should have
start a website showing your balls
dropping as you're losing weight.
So I'm what your balls are people.
I want to see that they do want to this.
I was just discussing this with you
because you're a certain interest in
mind
balls.
No investment on my balls.
I'm on the new homeless diet and weight.
Trying to lose 35 pounds and I'm not
shaving to ideal because I fucking hate
facial hair so much.
So it's making me want to fucking do it
quick and I've never met anybody like
you who goes so far down.
You lose all the weight and then you
gain it right back as soon as you start
dating the chick.
Because I would go out to eat so much.
I haven't dated someone that likes to
cook.
You know?
It seems like a date,
all these out.
What it is.
Yeah.
It's just so it's a food thing.
I eat out every night.
You get just get crazy and just gorge.
No,
I just,
you know,
it's just,
it's just normal.
I just,
I don't know,
but yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
but I've lost 14 pounds in a week and a
half being skinny.
Skinny.
You left metabolisms jacked man.
Why don't you just start working out
hard?
Just just one hour.
One hour.
Like weightlifting.
When you weight lift man,
you burn off so many calories.
Just you don't have to like lift heavy.
Just get like 25 pound dumbbells and do
cleans and kettlebells.
Great.
I'm going to get a Kettlebell.
Twenty five pound kettle bells.
All you need.
Do I do this one crazy cardio workout?
It's a DVD that I do with just 1:35
pound kettle bells.
It seems like.
How?
How's that even going to get you tired,
dude?
It gets.
Your heart is flying and so your heart's
like 100 8,690
beats a minute and it takes forever to
recover.
It's fucking hard,
man.
It's a brutal,
brutal workout.
One little cowbell just moving your
whole body,
making your whole body when you do
something like that.
Dude,
you can eat whatever the fuck you want.
You know,
it's crazy as that resveratrol or
whatever I've been taking for the last
three weeks.
That shit has destroyed my,
uh,
appetite.
Like I get full so fast now in or I
don't even feel hungry.
Will you show that seems like a bunch of
different changes in your personal?
Absolutely.
But that was one of the things my dad
told me that it did for him.
So I'm like,
oh,
really?
Yeah.
But now it's like,
I really have a hard time trying to eat
right now.
It's ridiculous.
It's like I'd be halfway through a salad
and I'll be like,
oh,
we're going,
we're going with Joey Italian Deli
place.
Placed the sausage and pepper subs.
Oh,
put some makeup.
Brave dog.
It makes dieting easier.
You're hanging onto bill burrs comb like
it's your best touching that.
There's things in it is
old school.
He carries a Komen,
has pocket show to the camera.
Joey.
Bill Burr.
Show that towards the camera.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
you got it.
Bill Burr.
So old school.
He carries a comb in his pocket.
And when he was here he left it.
So we're just going to leave it here out
of respect until bill burr returns.
We're just gonna leave it on his spot.
That's a seat.
I won't let him.
Hey Joey,
smell it and tell me what it smells
like.
She was like red head.
So it was like red little nubbies shit.
Did you guys hear about that?
Foxcom Shit.
That company.
That's a.
We talked about it several times in the
past.
This is the,
but he did.
They make iphone and their employees are
killing themselves and shit,
right?
Well they put up a suicide nets now.
So,
uh,
thank God that if.
Can you imagine just being somebody
that's like,
Hey,
I might get a job at Foxconn,
you know,
and then you're like,
like touring the job at during your job
interview and you're like,
you're like,
what's that?
And they're like,
oh,
that's a suicide net.
Why would you be like,
oh fuck,
I don't think I want to work here.
This shit.
He didn't commit suicide,
but you got a free pass free shot.
Imagine you jump.
You're like,
fuck it,
Shit.
I should've done this.
A net.
Yeah,
I think it might be fun.
That might be what if everyone just
starts trying to dive in,
dive in.
Fun.
If you're working in a place that sucks,
is that bad that so many people are
killing themselves.
They have to have nets up.
Chances are jumping in those nets be
funny as shit.
Yeah,
but anyways,
they're about to open another company or
another location.
Really?
Yeah,
for $300,000.
Well,
you know,
we've talked about this before.
You can't get a fucking iphone for 200
bucks if you're paying the people to
work for you.
Yeah.
You just got to get slave labor.
You got to get people to work for
fucking bowls of rice or $16,
16 hour days and isn't the iphone and
most electronics made by precious metals
or like,
you know,
like where people were shot daily for
these,
you know,
all this shit is going on in
Afghanistan.
A lot of what they're going to get out
of the ground there is shit to make an
iphone.
Right?
Exactly.
It is.
It's fucking incredible.
Fine.
A trillion dollars with a mineral.
So like we just found it.
We didn't even know it was there.
Meanwhile they said the Soviet Union
discovered this shit 30 years ago.
I just couldn't figure out how to get it
out and couldn't figure it out.
How to fucking control the region.
What,
what the fuck are we do?
Joe Diaz?
Give us your wisdom.
What the fuck are we doing?
Having wars in 2010,
why do people still tolerate it?
Because the heroines kicking over there
in Afghanistan.
It's got to have something to do with
the heroin.
To do what you got to fucking do.
It hasn't stopped.
Got a stapled.
Think that it's ridiculous thing that
heroin has something to do with this
war,
but all you need to know,
and these are real facts,
is that over 90 percent of the world's
heroine is grown in Afghanistan.
Over 90 percent was the other temple.
Where the fuck is that money going?
Is it going to war lords?
Because if it is,
where's their private jets?
Okay,
where's the war,
Lord?
How come the warlord isn't living like
the fucking Sultan of Brunei?
You know why we're.
Where are they?
How come they don't have that money?
Maybe they don't.
They don't.
It's not like Mexico.
It's not just that heroin that shit's
coming straight to America son.
That shit's been flown in.
Barry Seals and the fucking new world
order.
They're all flying that shit in and
propeller Perry's seal.
Look,
barry seal up.
Educate.
These motherfucking CEO was a guy who
got killed.
He was bringing in drugs from South
America.
Guy Got murdered while he was going to
testify and he had bushes.
Phone number in his pocket.
Very barry seal was the definitive case.
He was connected to every single,
like big time drug dealer,
Pablo Escobar,
all those guys,
everybody in South America,
this guy is connected to and he got
busted in Mena,
Arkansas.
They dropped a package off.
What they used to do is they would fly
in,
he would fly in from South America and a
little propeller plane flying to
Arkansas,
dropped a package off in Paris by
parachute,
get out of the plane,
and then the guys would go at the drop
spot and pick up the parachute.
They show up in a pickup truck or
whatever they use.
Well,
some kids were fucking around in the
woods and these kids spotted the
parachute drop and when they went to go
pick up the package,
they saw these kids.
They're so.
They killed the kids and they took the
kids bodies and they laid them on the
tracks and yeah.
And the autopsy came back so that the
kids were high and they fell asleep on
the tracks.
So the parents said,
that's ridiculous.
My,
my,
my children didn't do drugs.
I don't believe you.
So the parents paid for their own
autopsies and their own autopsy was
concluded that the kids were murdered,
that they were stabbed,
they found stab wounds on the body,
so the parents like started trying to
figure out what the fuck went wrong and
they started figuring out who landed
planes and what happened and blah blah
blah blah.
And then they busted Scott Barry Seals
and bearings seals a fucking employee of
the CIA who had been flying drugs into
this country for decades.
And he said that that's just what they
do.
That's what they've always done.
There's money out there to be made and
they know it and they make it and you
talking about the same people that are
willing to start wars.
They're willing to do that whole Gulf of
Tonkin thing.
We went to the Vietnam War war under
false pretenses and false flag attack
just in order to make sure that we're
involved in disputes with other
countries and one of the things they do.
We're involved with disputes over other
countries as they jacked or natural
resources and one of their natural
resources or drugs.
And what you don't think that
Afghanistan is a fucking gigantic money
hole for those evil scumbags that are
willing to do shit like that.
There's so much money there.
How do you,
what the fuck do you do when there's 90
percent of the world's anything in one
spot that's worth billions of dollars?
Billions.
But it's a ridiculous thing.
If you say it,
you're a nut.
If you start saying,
part of the reason why we're in
Afghanistan is because someone's making
money off drugs.
That's the,
that's definitely got to be something to
do with it.
People think you're crazy.
It's not the whole reason we're there.
But if you don't think it plays a part,
you don't think it has a saying who's
making money during the war.
You've got to fight that fucking war.
We think finances this shit,
you know?
Well,
you know,
the whole thing that happened during the
Reagan administration with the Contras,
you know,
and uh,
when the,
that Michael Rupert Guy Busted the CIA
selling drugs in Los Angeles,
ghettos,
you know,
all that stuff is,
that's just standard operational
procedure.
It just takes a while for it to pop out
and get into the new sometimes.
You know,
what the fuck do you see Ari Shaffir on
tmz today?
Yeah.
That's great.
I was there.
That was a fun time.
But uh,
he uh,
him in a way that Rowdy Roddy Piper a
got a Roddy Roddy Piper beat him up on
stage.
Well,
we're,
I'm thinking that he would really was a
racist,
which is a big problem with that
character.
He does.
People don't know that it's an act,
you know,
that he's just trying to get people's
reactions and just be a nut and have
people react to this fake racist
characters.
So they get angry at him,
but he's not really racist.
Right.
Well,
he kind of is like,
everyone else kidding or he's not a
racist.
That is a very open mind and objective
person.
So it's kind of funny that already would
be playing this character,
the amazing racist because it was a
joke.
It was national lampoon and it should
have moved on,
but do you think he should have moved
on?
I think it should have.
I've told him many times.
Have you told him,
Brian,
what do you think the character has done
that was a,
you know,
the whole idea that character is done
and you don't want to really be known
for that.
If the calculus,
I would've kept doing videos as the
character with new ideas,
but I really want you to keep going.
I think at a certain point in time,
it's like how many stereotypes you're
going to experience it.
It's a joke.
You know,
you already did the job.
There was no reason to keep on doing the
same joke over and over again.
I think he didn't do a Jewish one and be
done because he had too much success
with it and he just got caught up in it
to keep it going.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
That's one of the most successful things
that he's done.
You know,
the National Lampoon thing,
pretty famous.
You don't see me make still making car
lisman sia videos.
You,
you know that.
That was probably my most successful
video I've done,
but yeah,
absolutely the best video I've ever
done.
That's actually what all the girls like
to that stuff.
It's Hilarious when the cat reacts to
your Forte.
There's one.
You see that one where I did.
Did Lindsay Lohan?
Yes,
I saw that too.
That was pretty ridiculous.
So now what happened when Lindsay Lohan,
because I drink that Kombucha shit and
everybody's saying that Lindsay Lohan
lied and she said that her bracelet went
off because she was drinking that
Kombucha.
Kombucha has a,
there's a level of alcohol,
there's something going on with that
because it was pulled off the shelves
off a whole foods and uh,
there's some questioning about the
alcohol content that it's less than
one half of a percent,
right?
You don't have to mark it,
but if it's more than one half of a
percent,
you have to market and they're saying
it's more.
Right.
So she was wearing winter this scam
bracelets and it went off and supposedly
that's what made it go off.
Now I don't know if that's true or not,
but
you know,
they say that you're not even supposed
to have any Kombucha.
If you're an alcoholic,
you're not supposed to drink that shit.
Even taste like alcohol,
you know,
it does.
You know,
I was rolling.
I did Jujitsu after I drank one and this
dude's head.
Did you have a beer before you went to
juices and.
No,
drinking Kombucha.
It's all healthy and shit.
Right?
But I mean maybe it has this little tiny
bit of alcohol in it,
but I've never gotten drunk off it or
even felt a buzz.
But I'll tell you one thing man.
It's pumped.
My fucking immune system are through the
roof.
Yeah.
Don't get sick anymore.
How many do you have?
A day?
One.
At least two.
Wow.
Yeah,
a drink like two a day.
All the time.
I love them.
I'd fuck it.
I think they're delicious.
Do you like the regular?
The best?
I like the regular.
That's my favorite.
Yeah.
I'm not a big fan of that.
That other one?
No,
they're great.
One to show gingerade the Ginger Ale.
I like this kind of strong.
It's got a kick to it,
but the regular ones.
Fantastic.
But I'm telling you man,
all this travel I do.
I was getting sick all the time.
It was like every couple months I was
battling and I'm still working out.
Right.
I'm still training,
I'm working out as hard as I've ever
worked out and I'm not getting sick.
It's crazy and I think it has to do with
the probiotics,
staying really regular with your
vitamins.
That's very important,
but it's also maintaining a healthy
bacteria level in your body.
Acidophilus and probiotic drinks on the
road.
I take the acidophilus with me and I
just,
you know,
take that.
And when I'm at home I drink those
fucking drinks and I'm not getting sick.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
You're supposed to so many different
varieties of germs and bullshit when
you're on the road.
Plus I'm way more careful now,
but like washing my hands before I eat
and strange.
Is that the creek we look at.
What about the job that got it?
The fucking the fetal this weekend.
Let's,
let's talk about this.
Is this is the bottom line failed or had
never fought.
A guy who's got a
garlic for doom and who is he training
with?
He's not training with anybody like is
top of the food chain Abu Dhabi champion
and he's a big man.
He's like six foot three,
six,
four.
He's a big fucking dude and he's good.
His guard is nasty.
He's got one of the best cars in the
world.
You try getting sloppy with grounded
pound leave arms in there.
He got snatched those arms up quick and
he's got a tight game and the beginning
of the round Fado wasn't slippery yet.
You know,
no one's sweaty and they're just barely
broken a sweat.
So He's got like a nice grip on a man
and you know,
we're doing man.
You let them catch you and you in a
technique battle.
You battle his guard from,
from,
you know when you're on top and you
leave an arm in there,
he's gonna fuck you up man.
Because as you go to defend,
he set him up man.
And you know,
it was really beautiful to watch what he
did.
He attacked the arm and as fate or is
defending the arm,
he's got a pull the arm back.
So as he's defending the arm,
pull the arm back.
That's when he slaps a triangle on.
It's like he just put him in a classic
Brazilian Jujitsu chain of submissions.
He went,
one,
you defend this.
He goes to that,
and as you defend the triangle,
you expose the arm.
As you protect the arm,
the triangle gets locked deeper.
Bang,
Bang.
It was beautiful man.
It was beautiful.
Look fate or is a bad motherfucker.
He's really like a guy who could fight
at two.
Oh,
five easy.
And he's fighting at heavyweight
knocking guys out.
You know,
he's only six feet tall.
He's not a big guy.
Some people say he's actually only 5:11.
He's not a big guy,
but he's incredibly talented and
incredibly inspirational.
You know,
he's a,
he's a dude that makes people,
you know,
like,
excited,
you know,
they love the way he carries himself,
the way he handled the last man to hear
what he said afterwards.
I said,
how do you feel?
Right?
And he says,
I feel nothing goes [inaudible] you.
Uh,
you can't stand it.
Yeah.
You have to.
People who don't fall don't know what
it's like to stand.
When was his last fight?
Like main fight before?
That wasn't like seven years ago or
something.
We don't know.
What are people saying?
You know he beat Brett Rogers less than
a shit.
It was only a few months ago.
Months ago.
Less than probably a blast and I'm
knocked him out,
but right after he beat them,
Alistair overeem beat the fuck out of
Brett Rogers.
Alistair overeem own bread.
Rogers.
He.
The way he did it,
man was so precise on the feet,
just high level.
Fucking Moitai tie.
Slipping the punch and the Shin slams
into the meat of the lake.
You could see like right away,
Brett Rogers like,
oh fuck.
Like you could see right away.
He was in way,
way,
way over his head.
And then Alastar got Brett,
Raj on the ground and fucking pummeled
them.
It moves.
It was a ridiculously one sided fight.
What kind of party is Dana White having
this weekend?
It's having a big party and having a
fucking laugh your ass off.
I just saved $30,000,000
because now fate or unfortunately really
does become irrelevant because part of
what made him exciting was the fact that
he was this undefeated guy who seemed to
be a superhuman and destroys tim.
Silvia destroys Andre Arlovski is like
there's an aura about him.
Some of the aura was eroded slightly by
the Brett Rogers fight because Brett
Rogers got him down,
was grounded,
pounded him,
was connecting with big shots and you
looked at it and you're like,
what if brock got him in that spot?
If Baraka Baraka named Brett Rogers pro
brock gets you in that spot a,
you're not getting up.
B,
you're going to eat some giant cinder
block.
Fucking canned ham fists this weekend.
They're going to be crazy limitations.
So I,
I,
so anyway,
that eroded people's confidence in fate
or a little bit,
but what eroded my confidence,
and it is when I saw the way alice star
handled Brett Rogers,
I knew Alastar
was going to fuck bro,
but I didn't know he's going to do it
like that.
The way he did it was perfect.
I mean,
he just,
he shows how high level,
his striking is me beat Badr Hari,
not Badr Hari Out,
who is one of the very best kick boxers
in the world,
you know,
he's,
he's beaten a lot of dudes.
He fucked up Peter Hertz,
you know,
he,
he knocks dudes out,
man.
He's a bad motherfucker in kickboxing
with the best in the world,
you know,
he's hanging with those guys.
So when he got in there again,
it's like an MMA fighter who's just a
brawler.
He just opened up a can on them and you
know,
fate or is not a technical striker.
He's very explosive and very fast and
you know,
he's good and tough and his technique is
good,
but he's not like a guy who could just
step into k one the way our star does.
And Alastar has a nasty ground game as
well.
So the transition between the two of
them is very smooth.
And when he took Brett Rogers down,
he just controlled him on the ground and
beat the fuck out of him.
He really made a mockery over Faye doors
when,
I mean,
it wasn't,
you know,
I mean,
obviously it wasn't the same night.
It's not the same circumstances,
but the way he beat him,
I was like,
man,
you know,
Alastar to me is more exciting really
right now than Fader al stores.
That's one of the scariest guys in the
divisionK.
,
one level,
high level striking and nasty Brazilian
Jujitsu one,
the,
uh,
European Abu Dhabi trials submitted Vito
Belfort instead of fucking sick.
He a team man,
what do you think fader or would have to
do to earn back?
You're like,
wow,
that is on top of his game.
Like who would he have to fight with?
You have to go to the UFC now or you'd
have to go to the UFC and I've or fight
Alastar and then go to the UFC,
but in for doom again too.
I mean,
I'm excited to see him fight anybody.
It's not that I'm not afraid or fan.
I love him,
but I think you've got to fight the best
guys in the world.
You got to be in the heat with the best
guys in the world and there's really no
shortcuts for that.
There's no shortcuts for,
for training with a guy like for real
silver dome.
There's no shortcuts to learning how to
get out of a guard like that.
You've got to experience it and it's
pretty obvious watching that fight that,
you know,
he probably hadn't,
hadn't experienced that kind of shit
before,
you know,
I mean,
he was,
he's made some critical errors.
There's a beautiful video where I'm
Henry Gracie and his brother breakdown
what would fade or did wrong and what
we're doing.
It was playing the triangle as
beautiful,
you know,
and it's like,
people are looking at and they're like,
this is like simple Jujitsu.
He made mistakes and part of these mix
tapes,
because he's got a very unorthodox
style.
He throws big haymakers inside the
guard.
He's been really successful with that.
But with a guy like for doom,
you can't do that.
He,
he's just,
he's there to catch those little tiny,
tiny openings,
you know,
he put a beating on him that,
you know what it was really exciting
about that nightmare.
Kung Lee is bringing a taekwondo back
country,
has that fucking step in turning
sidekick.
He stands in a southpaw stance with his
right leg forward and he throws a left
like steps for throwing a left and dudes
back out of the way,
just of the punch,
but at turning sidekick comes behind it.
So it's a 360 degree turning sidekick.
He stands with his right leg forward,
throws the lefthand,
and as he throws the lefthand,
he steps forward with the left foot and
then spins.
So there's so much momentum and he's
like running
at you with that kick and blasts you
his.
He's doing shit with kicks man that
other people aren't doing.
And that's one of them.
The way he throws that three 60 turning
sidekick.
I don't see anybody else doing that.
If you guys do a turning sidekick,
but I don't see anybody else doing that
three 60 like he does it and his kicks
are fucking deadly man.
There was a lot of high kicks to,
you know.
What do you think for this weekend so
far they're sucking.
Talk less.
There's a lot of fights I'm excited
about on this card.
How about Chris?
Lionel versus Matt?
The shit that man,
that motherfucker that fight has fight
of the night.
Written all over at both guys are
savages.
Brown is a fucking savage.
And Chris Lidell no.
Back Down to shit.
Chris Lidell.
I've never even seen that guy get
rocked.
I've seen them get busted open and
bloody and smashed in the face and hit
with Haymakers,
but he always just bounces right back.
That dude's Chin has made us a meant.
Here's a fucking monster.
And Him and Matt Brown.
Matt Brown as a warrior.
Do that guy go fucking fuck.
I strong.
His mind is strong too.
He represses.
He keeps taze onto it and breaks dudes.
So him in Lidl is just a guaranteed
fucking guaranteed.
Tons of fun.
By the way.
Mad props to the UFC,
his new website.
That's fucking amazing.
You like that?
It's fucking awesome if you don't think
it's too much flash.
Uh,
well,
I mean it's one of those fund websites,
you know,
like,
I mean it's kind missed the old one.
Yeah.
Like I liked the,
I mean there's not a choice to do just
the basic,
like a blog or something like that.
It's pretty dope though.
When you do see like the different
fighters and you're like they focus on
each frame and match up.
It's there like big closeup pictures and
shit.
And that is Flash,
Huh?
Yeah.
It's unfortunate that it's flash,
but uh,
it's pretty sweet.
I like it.
They could have done the same thing with
html five.
I'm sure there probably is a way to do
that and that way you could get it on
your ipad or your iphone.
Right?
Because right now you can't write what
the fun stuff that's not like
informative,
like DVD extras when you want to be able
to get that on your phone.
Yeah,
I guess it's just not.
It's cool to look at pictures and stuff.
I guess,
isn't it crazy that porn is what's
pushing the transition to html five when
porn back something?
It's usually pretty legit.
You know?
Isn't that nuts?
Fuck.
Is anybody still making money off porn?
Know?
You know we've talked about this.
Yeah.
Tyler,
no.
Tyler night.
That dude,
he's um,
he's making a transition to becoming an
author.
He's a really good writer.
He wrote some really fucked up shit if
you don't know what his blog is,
but it just look up tyler night blog,
you'll find it online and tyler is a
really good writer,
but he's got some ridiculous stories
about porno sets and scenes and he's got
a story about failing at a boot khaki
khaki event.
Whereas like literally hundreds of dudes
are fucking this chick and you know,
he's in line with all these dudes and
he's trying to keep his dick hard and
right.
And he gets somebody totally fails and
stepping,
stepping other dudes loads.
There's loads every.
It's so dark,
but it's so well written too.
It's just really awesome stuff.
But having all true,
I would have those,
a pool shoes and slippers that you.
How about cleats?
Cleats would be better,
so softball cleats.
Just dig your way through the fucking
sticky loads.
What the fuck?
But this guy was in the porn business
forever,
man and had some great,
great stories about the porn business
and now he's just writing,
you know and shit.
Just stories about the porn business can
keep me fascinated for years.
That's a crazy business dude and he's a
regular really cool.
Nice guy.
Do you ever see the cosby's episode or
the Cosby's porno?
Thomas Ward.
I hang out with that dude two weeks ago.
Where was he at?
The comedy store with one of his porn
star friends.
Real and she was like,
I needed their contacts and she's all
like all in my face and I'm like,
oh,
you smell like crack and Doritos.
Crack and Doritos and VD.
Yeah.
Oh she was Thomas Ward is a really funny
guy.
Man.
Thomas Ward was another guy that like.
I always was like,
how come Thomas Ward didn't hit?
How come?
How come you didn't make it?
He's loving it now,
man.
It seems like he's.
Looks like he's living large now.
He's doing porn.
Yeah,
he's winning awards and stuff.
I don't think he actually does the porn
part though.
He just does like acting in porn.
But he's like winning,
winning awards.
Winning porn awards.
Yeah.
Do those count.
They do count.
Joey.
Joey,
we lost him still.
I was in said my blood sugars down the
air conditioning is what's my air
conditioning is broke in my office.
It's being replaced on Tuesday.
So what's today?
Wednesday?
Tuesday.
Tomorrow.
You gotta wait a week to week you.
They got to order all the parts and all
that shit.
So there's no,
no,
no.
The House has there.
Just not my office.
And he opened the back window.
Yeah.
It gets hot as fuck in the valley.
That's one of the things I miss about
Colorado and never really got that hot.
My house in Colorado,
no need for air conditioning.
Ever Tie.
Just opened up a window.
Beautiful.
Clean Mountain air.
Have some fucking tap water in your tap
water is uh.
Well how about that?
Sun and drinking water out of a fucking
stream.
It's in the earth.
So when I moved back to Colorado,
but Mrs Rogan,
so not down for getting another dog
eaten by a monster in the woods.
That's what chloroforms for chloroform,
the fucking dog and chloroforms for it
and what's not.
Wake up.
Where are we?
You're in California.
You can't live with someone and kidnap
him.
Moving to another state.
Especially with babies and shit.
It's a lot of work through the
chloroform run is.
Wait,
where are you at this weekend?
What are you doing this weekend?
I got a couple of shows Friday.
Tell people where to where they can see
it.
Sounds comedy.
Motherfucking whole.
Yeah.
Sounds.
Comedy is a new place that I want to
check it out.
Tell me about this place on labrea
cells.
Comedy horror.
You've been there twice though.
Whereas this is very avant garde.
Libray and melrose.
Melrose.
I guess that's where it is.
What are you asking me fucking because I
want to know about it.
I've never been there before.
It's a new place in that way.
Just give me some prompts.
I'm fucking tired.
Let's go get a sausage and peppers
saying,
oh,
Joey died.
He faded.
Honestly.
Imagine that,
imagine if your job,
if you can fall asleep after two hours.
So it's a good spot though.
Comedy,
hold on.
Friday night,
late night.
I have no fucking idea.
He's going to call it.
Okay,
so call sales comedy whole.
I don't even give a fuck.
Don't call comedy.
Hold.
Don't bother me.
I'm going to the Improv and someone's in
La and they're looking for some comedy
late night show at the Improv,
which are the level two weekends.
Ten o'clock.
Friday,
10.
That's the refi beans?
Yes.
Okay.
So what time is your spot?
I have no idea when you're on that show,
so if you want to see some good comedy,
go to the Improv.
Ten,
10:00
show.
Friday night joe is will be there and
Brian and I will be a w at the Vegas,
a house of Blues on Friday night.
Me and Sam Tripoli and then on Saturday
we're going to go to the UFC Saturday.
It's from your sponsor and all that
stuff.
I can't wait for.
What do you think's gonna happen when
Shankar wouldn't brock lives now?
I've been thinking about it.
I think Brock Lesnar is going to win
this first round.
First round.
Huh?
What do you think?
Take them down.
Pound on them.
Hound them to death and it's going to be
stopped.
Do you think that uh,
Shane Carlin won't be able to stop brock
from taking them down?
Yeah,
I think is just a monster and you can't
stop when that fist is coming at you and
it's just gonna keep on coming and I
think he's just going to get smashed
brained.
Really?
Yup.
So you don't.
What about the fact that chain car one
is literally.
I mean physically at least on paper,
the same size,
you know,
it weighs the same amount and he's
knocked out every single person bro.
It's a fucking different dance.
He's a big debts.
There's a big fucking rock has been
there before.
You know,
how was a big fucking dead rock is so
competitive and he really feels that.
I bet he needs to come back.
He's just got a lot of time to think
about shit and a lot of training to do
and he's just,
he's gonna.
He's gonna probably be more ready now
than he's ever been in his life.
I thought,
well,
you know,
he's not even cutting weight is walking
around at like two 65.
He's lost weight,
but fat.
He's like ripped.
It was looking really good chicken like
his,
his mass is thick because now he's on
this really a vegetable diet and you
know,
high in fiber and you know Broccoli and
shit like that to go along with the
meat.
So he's got this diet that's like a
cleaner diet and he watches his food.
Like the countdown show was pretty
interesting when we were talking about
him coming back and they started out
nice and slow.
He worked out,
they made sure his heartbeat heart rate
didn't go over certain beats per minute
and then they slowly built them back so
they could see the beast return,
you know?
And then before,
you know what he's fucking 280 pounds
again,
throwing people around.
That'd be funny.
If his tattoo grew like ets flower got
dead,
you know?
But anyway,
what if someone actually tattooed a dick
on their chest just like it?
No.
Look at Dick like no question at all.
Like a dick.
Would they let them fight in the UFC?
What if you got a guy like Hector
Lombard who's like the,
uh,
bellatore champion,
very highly touted middleweight one of
the best in the world.
But what if a guy like that level
decided to Kinda like go me would've
gotten me cable into the UFC and he
tattooed a dick on his chest.
Probably make them cover it up,
you know,
how are you making.
I cover it up.
They have makeup there was in the way
and put makeup on fight Madison.
It would take marker,
maybe like permanent marker.
Mark.
Draw.
Make it look like a person that someone
did that.
Um,
from the uh,
the wolf's lair.
What the fuck is his name?
Shit.
God,
goddammit.
You know,
it'd be awesome if a fighter came out,
the English guy,
Paul Kelly,
Paul Teles,
Kelly,
he,
um,
he had,
he left the wolf's lair so he had like
marker and he put a big x across the
wolf's lair on his back because he had
tattooed the wolf's lair on his back.
You know,
it'd be awesome what a fighter shit do
what as they said,
draw all over their face that make it
look like they passed out at a party,
you know,
like,
like have dicks and Cox,
those chemicals on your skin.
You can get someone's.
I would sweat.
You can't do that.
He can't put anything on you.
Not even mean.
That's why after the GSP,
Bj Penn fight corners aren't even
allowed to put vaseline on.
They have to cut man and have to do it.
And they control it.
Huh?
Yeah.
It's um.
I don't know.
What if someone did though,
what if someone did,
do you think that would be you can't
fight made event fight main event,
fight big event like a Tesla car when
type thing like GSP,
GSP is going to have this fucking big
crazy fight coming up with Josh
Koscheck.
Right.
You know,
and as you know,
he steps into the octagon.
He realized GSP has got a big dick
tattooed on his chest,
a real dick vein,
a black one,
a black dick.
He just got crazy and just decided to
give something to,
you know,
my idea is to distract people.
They concentrated on the book Dick,
you know,
somewhere in the contract.
You're not allowed to do that.
Yeah.
Probably no black dicks in your chest.
Think so.
Yeah.
It was probably something like that.
To find that out.
Why?
Guess?
Yeah.
I don't even want to ask them though,
because then looking.
Why the fuck are you asking me this?
You.
Hi.
We're going to start testing.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
that's about two hours.
So a Joey Diaz is a starving for a
sausage and pepper sandwich.
Old School,
like there's the give you a north Bergen
Bergen.
You go down to get a fucking sausage and
pepper.
You can't even get that shit.
These fucking half a fax.
They can make a god damn sandwich.
I want a fucking sausage and pepper.
We'll peppers and fucking Marinara
sauce.
What?
What's this flashlight thing?
Joey ideas.
Oh,
the mom totally got to do a word for the
fucking sponsor.
I've been telling you that we're a half
hour character.
This motherfucker stop fucking your
hand.
No,
that's fine.
Is the fleshlight a word from our
sponsor?
We've got to keep the lights on.
Ladies and gentlemen.
The way we do it is run by assholes.
That's what we do is keep the lights on.
It's soft.
It's wonderful.
It feels good.
If you leave it out in the sun,
it gets warm.
Have you can.
You can.
You can also put it in a tub full of hot
water.
That's a good move to fill the tub with
hot water bath tub with them.
Then
you squirt some lube,
put some lube in there,
and then you stick your erect penis and
then you'll like this.
I ain't even thought about doing it in
the shower.
The only problem with the flashlight is
as much of a losers.
You feel like when you jerk off,
you feel like five times more of a loser
when you nut into a rubber pussy,
you just feel like a fucking idiot,
but it's an outstanding product.
It's not like I'm gonna stop using it,
but you do feel completely ridiculous.
Like if somebody caught you beating off,
that'd be one thing,
but if you know your girl walks in and
you're like what you're putting into a
rubber pussy,
you're one of the most ridiculous things
you could ever get busted doing.
Yeah.
Fucking a rubber posing.
A real doll would probably be way worse.
So.
Yeah.
No,
that'd be totally way worse.
At least this way you like,
I know it's not a person.
I'm just watching porn have beaten off a
real doll is really kind of fucking
useless when you think about it.
How dumb do you have to be to really
think that you were having sex and I
would want one just to drive around with
in the car and do practical jokes and
stuff like that.
That's a good move.
But I think cops look now because I
think people have done shit like that
before.
I know people had been busted with masks
and stuff,
but if you put a fucking seat belt on
that sunglasses,
there's no way that cops gonna know
that's fake.
You know?
If you have tinted windows for short,
right?
Then there's nobody's gonna know,
put,
make it look like put a helmet on him
and bandages and shit like he's the
mommy.
Like something bad happen to him or like
her outfit.
The cop's going to investigate you.
You're the worst criminal of all time.
All right.
This weekend Joe Diaz is at Sal's comedy
whole on Friday night and the 10:00
PM show at the Improv.
Don't miss him.
It's epic.
Standup comedy.
It's real standup comedy.
Old School.
Joey,
we've got to make a fucking cd with you
this year.
Okay.
Can we do that?
We make a CD talking monkey productions.
I put that shit out.
Should we do a DVD or CD?
You should do a God damn DVD DVD.
It pains me to know and the Joe Diaz
does not have a naval.
This is going to be.
Even though you got a restraining order,
I'm still gonna fucking kill you.
That's the name of my app right there.
I like it.
We will go with that or what else he
decides tomorrow.
Even though you don't have a restraining
order,
I'm still going to fucking kill you.
Let's,
let's plan this out right now.
People know where we're going to play,
where we're going to do this.
Where should we do this?
Where should we do?
Do some with.
No,
we should do.
Here's what we should do.
We should I when I'm doing a weekend
somewhere like a Dallas weekend or
Austin or something like that where I'm
doing Friday and Saturday and Sunday.
How about we fly in Thursday?
Okay.
We,
we,
we put it up on twitter and the Internet
and I host it and I bring you up to do
it.
I bring you up.
Okay,
so let's plan on doing that next time.
One of the top videos that we shoot with
the tank next week in Burbank.
That'll be,
that's what we'll do.
I'll host it,
will bring you up and we'll have,
you know,
you'll do like do 45 minutes in,
five minutes banging out and we'll have,
you know,
it'd be fucking perfect.
Get it.
We need to do that.
We've been needing to do that for a long
time,
so if you need to see joey eventually
gonna get to see them on DVD.
But for now,
go to see him.
If you're in La Sal,
sal's comedy whole Friday night and the
Improv 10:00
PM show.
If you want to see me House of Blues
Night in Vegas Dot Com.
It's going to be the shit,
the House of Blues and the House of
Blues.
By the way,
if you've ever seen me there before and
it was chaos.
We completely revamped the whole
situation.
There's no more standing.
After we went to see doug,
Stan Hope Brian and I went to see Doug
Stan hope and the army went to and it
was so tiring.
Just standing up is awful.
It's hard.
I did not know.
Is that hard to watch a show?
I figured it was just like I'm standing
on stage for an hour and a half.
I think it's no big deal.
Stand and watch,
but it's a big deal.
It's annoying as fuck.
Especially because when I'm on stage I
can walk around and move and it doesn't
feel so made me hate the comedy when
you're standing and what you had to
stand in one spot too.
And I kept like moving my arms,
stretching my backstory,
not fun.
So I decided after that time,
no more standing room shows that we've
made one mistake.
We did Memphis,
that one fucking show in Memphis,
which was a disaster,
right?
There was fucking half the show was
standing and it was all a bar and
everybody was talking at the top of
their voice and it was,
there was no other venue available in
benefits when we were there.
So we took it.
But when the,
when we do the house of blues now
everybody seated.
So it,
it's like they had to cut out a few
hundred tickets,
a few hundred seats because they used to
let people,
like a few hundred people stand over by
the bar area.
But it became a disaster.
Everybody would talk and they would yell
shit out and they would annoy the fuck
out of the people that were sitting.
And so now it's sweet.
It's nice.
Everyone's seated.
So that is a 8:00
on Friday.
And then after that,
if you're around steel panthers at
midnight,
we're gonna.
Go see that.
Two Steel Panther.
The fucking the rock show.
It's the shit.
Yeah.
I can't wait.
Yeah,
it was going to be fun,
man.
God is the greatest Ozzy Osborne
impression in the history of the
universe.
All Right Ladies,
gentlemen,
thank you very much for tuning into the
podcast.
We appreciate it.
And we will be back next week.
And uh,
that's it.
We love you bitches.
Made it black.